[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey here we are yeah we're already
fighting over who's first and [ __ ] well
we're not yeah i don't care if i'm for
sure i'm always first because i'm the
one sitting here saying it's [ __ ]
stream up
for y'all who don't make the live
streams
that minute or so that we're getting
ready and running the [ __ ]
loading screen or whatever you want to
call it the warm-up screen
the [ __ ] that happens in the damn
combat sections is a trip because we all
started [ __ ] fighting over who was
first
i don't do it all the time but then i
get there and start messing with them
b's nest is in there murder hornets nest
is in there talking [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i see who else is in there dj maniac and
they're talking [ __ ] he's always first i
don't understand how he makes it pretty
much well in there before me
and you're saying i know what it's going
to start
well new york time we start well so are
we
[Laughter]
his time moves faster in new york oh
okay i guess yeah
so he's actually able to be first
because he's like a few minutes ahead of
us yeah it's like a time warp like a
time warp shirt i get it yeah
looking for them the time space
continuum goes a little bit
bit slower for them i guess
so you know the second for them is like
three is like four seconds for us
so yeah okay they can move fast that's
kind of like that star trek episode
where people were speeding up and it
sounded like a buzzing in your ear yeah
remember that they couldn't even see
them because they were walking in and
out
there was a there was a sketch on
mystery science theater where they did
that too where uh where they were all
like two or three seconds off from one
another because of like a time
distortion yeah
it's funny because you said like uh time
going faster in new york it reminded me
of this thing i was watching earlier
about
um
things like for europeans and stuff like
visiting the south and one of the things
they said that i thought was kind of
funny even though it doesn't it doesn't
apply like across the board but i know
what they're getting at so they said
like
if you are yeah if you come to the south
it's like when sp people says oh you
know we'll we'll be there at 8 o'clock
it's like yeah it might be more like 8
15 8 30 because people are like kind of
laid back and not really like worried
about right and i was like so you guys
know my mom
they're also not in a hurry i'm not like
that though i'm actually very punctual
uh yeah
we are
because well we you know we've been we
live we lived everywhere you know but no
you in mississippi the [ __ ] clock
doesn't really matter that much kind of
like the middle east is like that
in a way leggings just kind of sit
around i get that but on the other end
of that like to me it seems a little bit
like arrogant and rude because you're
making other people wait for you because
you are clearly more important than them
you know what i mean just don't they
just don't see things that way i know
but that's kind of but well because well
because they're not the ones on the
receiving end of it that's why no they
know what i mean yeah i mean they don't
care
but no they'll be in a line waiting and
they don't care well that's not that's
not what i'm talking about i'm talking
more about like if you're going to meet
somebody and you said hey let's go meet
somebody like at x you know time and you
know the person that has to wait around
for your dumb ass it's like i'm not
going to think you're laid back i'm just
going to think you're a jerk you know i
don't
i don't recall that actually i think
that's something i i in mississippi we
didn't do that if you meet up before
clocks in before
yeah but if you go to a store
and there's people in line
waiting for the checkout
you know you're at the local grocery
store there might be two or three people
ahead of you everybody knows each other
and the [ __ ] cash you're just talking
to the person yeah you know what i mean
they're checking because they know
they're going to talk to everybody
you know because there's only going to
be [ __ ] 10 people in the store that
day
probably
certainly slower i mean i get that too
but i mean i was born in the south but
even so i'm just kind of like hurry up
some of us have [ __ ] to do
depends on where you are i get like real
well you know my dad was real impatient
even though he was born in the south too
so i think i got a lot of that i'm a
very very impatient person i'm just like
let's go move it along where my dad
lives in
in uh heidelberg mississippi like i said
like there's 600 people there now
there's still kind of a main street with
a couple of stores on it oh no man
[ __ ] they're lucky to get three or
four customers a day it's gonna be slow
chucking in and out it's like an event
it's a social event whoa we got somebody
in early yeah
yeah the whole bagging process because
you don't have anywhere to go
if you have somewhere to go you wouldn't
be living there
that's true
yeah
you would not be living there so it's
not yeah so it's not like you're holding
anybody no anything's super powerful
and uh yeah grant there's hammers and i
wanted to bring this up too grand
there's amber said speaking of time
warps meatloaf passed away yesterday yes
he did yeah uh louie anderson died too
yeah although i will say
uh this is funny because somebody else
somebody else also mentioned that too i
thought louis anderson uh died a few
years ago but i guess not i was maybe
thinking to somebody else graham i got
today's open live friday people i know
people are starting to just uh come in i
think we're at 20. it's open lines
friday anything you guys want to [ __ ]
talk about we'll we can talk about it
just drop it in the comment section we
do have some stuff lined up you know if
the show gets kind of dead we can talk
about some of those uh urban legends
from the last show we had a bunch of
them although we covered a lot more of
them than i thought we did when i went
back through my notes i was kind of like
oh well there's like some that i could
still talk about but so we don't have to
talk about that yeah but you know what i
mean uh i wanted to tell graham that uh
had a special delivery today uh from psa
i got my first [ __ ] nickel boron
[ __ ] bolt carrier group for ar-15
i wanted chrome but you can't get them
anymore i don't you know
the companies that make them
they're just they're never in stock
so i got that nickel boron it's a tool
co a tool craft toolcraft but it's
unmarked tool craft that's who made it
man it looks [ __ ] fine man
i was studying before i got it
they were on sale man
you can run them dry
i didn't know i just like cold put a
light coat of that down
high temperature wheel bearing grease on
them
on on the main part of the body wipe it
dry just so it's kind of slick
i think that might be the way to go
today
21st century that nickel boron
it looks pretty good
murder hornet return says i hate those
people at the pharmacy that hold up the
line asking questions when they've
probably been taking that same meds for
years
yeah i've seen like a lot of people do
that and i'm kind of like well that's
the reason i thought that many years ago
now they give you that really exhaustive
printout
that says what all the side effects are
and like you know call the doctor if
this that and the other thing i'm like
that's why they're giving you that so
you don't have to like sit there and
interrogate the pharmacist because of
this [ __ ] to do
and uh yeah and he says always old
people just get your [ __ ] and move on
pretty much i mean you know i don't i
hate to pick on old people because i'm
old too but i mean i'm not that old but
i mean man you p you got coupons for
everything you're paying with change get
the [ __ ] out of here with that it's the
21st century we didn't know we don't
need to do that anymore just stop being
so [ __ ] slow
some of us got places to be
it's funny because uh remember we were
talking about
because when we were in high school
and um you know you could leave to go to
lunch in some places
so most of the time uh if i had money
like uh and i didn't bring my lunch then
there was a mcdonald's right behind the
high school so a lot of us just kind of
walk over there and get something to eat
like real quick and it seemed that
every single time that you went there
there was like this massive line of
senior citizens
getting lunch at the same time that the
high school kids were trying to get
lunch and we only had 50 minutes like to
get food and eat it and go back to class
and
but it seemed like the older people just
didn't give
zero [ __ ] about that they gave zero
[ __ ] about that they're like nope we're
just gonna sit in here all day and
hand and haul and pay with change and
have coupons and [ __ ] like that yeah
this is like back in the late 80s though
which is asking me at the bcg estate
this is all [ __ ] code if you guys
don't know what we're talking about you
just don't know uh yeah they're all
staked anything mil-spec or above is
going to be staked but here's the thing
man this internet is [ __ ] funny
they they'll take one little small thing
and they'll focus in on it like oh it's
not staked enough
it just you just don't want the damn
allen screws to rotate and even
even unstaked as long as it was done
correctly and you had the torque specs
proper especially if you put something
like red loctite in it it's not gonna
come on steak it's like that damn castle
nut on the back of them [ __ ]
uh uh
[ __ ] buffer tube oh it's gotta be
[ __ ] steak no it doesn't it does not
have to be staked
they staked that [ __ ] on gi [ __ ] uh
ar um ar15s and [ __ ] m4s because they
wanted to keep [ __ ] joe snuffy
out of that damn
rear end because the past inspections he
tried to take that castle nut off and
get in there and clean [ __ ] that way
he couldn't get dinged in an inspection
they just didn't want
troops taking that off
if you [ __ ] torque at the spec it
won't it won't loosen and if it does
loosen the buttstock doesn't fall off
people think it'll fall apart it won't
um so i never [ __ ] stake those
[ __ ] castle nuts it's [ __ ] stupid
talking to spec
zach says why does it always seem like
groups of celebrities dial at once in
some periods i don't know if it's so
much i don't know i guess like with
anything uh you're gonna get clustering
and honestly i think what happens yeah
because we've had like for louis
anderson died meatloaf died betty white
died and bob saggett died i think that
celebrities are probably like popping
their clogs all the time but it's only
the ones that have reached a level of
fame where everybody knows who they are
instead of just like a kind of a smaller
group so maybe that's why i'm not really
sure
um lee warner says who is sexier in
their prime susie sue or debbie harry
debbie harry ooh that's a tough one yeah
it's gonna be hard
i'm probably gonna lean that way too but
that's kind of like
uh that's my opinion it's a hard
question because they're both like sexy
in different ways i guess
as a man if you'd ask me which one i
want to hit it'd be debbie harry
uh although when it came to [ __ ] like
artistic prowess and creativity susie
by
far
susie was a lot more goth
but in terms of just attracted
attractiveness i think [ __ ] debbie
harry deborah harry was [ __ ] more
attractive
there was something like yeah there was
like something really really sexy about
her yeah
she had a good facial structure and
stuff
although i you know i must admit neither
one of those girls actually had the
the body styles that i like they're both
kind of
just average but their face they had
good faces they were [ __ ] really cool
i mean particularly debbie harry she was
very very thin back in the 70s but
that's kind of like what the it was
popular then that was what the style was
uh susie looks more like just a regular
yeah size person ask me about bump
stocks do i like bump stocks no [ __ ]
[ __ ] boss bump stocks
people [ __ ] want to emulate full auto
full auto full auto only existed because
mil-spec triggers [ __ ] suck it's a
real [ __ ] a lot of creep a lot of
stacking and then then it's [ __ ] a
hard break and then there's a bunch of
[ __ ] slack behind the trigger then
the reset is [ __ ] shitty on a on a
mil-spec trigger you can't really pull
it very quickly
so what for safety reasons they did that
on purpose that way joe [ __ ] the rag man
or joe snuffy [ __ ] you know what i
mean look at just some drafty kid
you could hand him a weapon and he
wouldn't wouldn't accidentally discharge
it that's all it was about you put a
match trigger with a [ __ ]
real [ __ ] crisp break [ __ ] five
pound even six pounds
with uh
no over travel and a real short reset
you can pull that trigger fast
uh you can
if you ask me you can top full auto
rates of rates of fire and maintain
controllability
uh and you don't need full auto fire
that's it's not very effective
um
not for not for the not for what an
assault rifle does which is a car beat
really
now if you're talking about something
like a mac 10 or an m3 you know a sub
machine gun
yeah full auto kind of makes more sense
because that's it's pistol caliber and
it's meant for up close and confined
areas especially if it's suppressed it's
a lot more of a pussycat to shoot
yeah maybe full auto on that would be
nice to have but also then again also
not a deal breaker a real slick [ __ ]
nine millimeter
small
sub type gun with a good trigger
nice you know okay delta back in the day
when delta force was really good they
didn't use full auto they used semi auto
it's a lot more controllable
single accurate shots that connect it's
just more efficient
that's all i'm gonna say
hugo says jenny i like your shirt thank
you i've worn it several times i got it
at uh fye of all places i was at the
mall
uh before a movie and there's an fye
right by the food court and they had
like they have like a whole series of
these they're really rad i can't
remember like the name of the it's on
here somewhere but they're like the name
of the company that makes them they had
all the old universal monster movies and
they had like a bunch of 70s movies like
they had jaws and texas chainsaw
massacre and stuff like in all these
kind of like really cool like bold
designs with like a japanese on them and
stuff and it's like i i really like them
a lot i wanted a bunch of them but this
is this is my favorite one let me do a
part two to what i said
full auto when does it matter bell feds
belfed's fire support weapon hell yeah
that you want [ __ ] full auto
especially if it's something that's
aviation inspired you know with between
airplanes or aircrafts or helicopters
mini guns on helicopters and aircraft
yeah you want full auto
but for small arms full auto
you don't really need it
you know good semi-auto where is that
zach says what's weird is jack nicholson
was weirdly sexy back in the 70s and i
can't put my finger on why he's catching
he had a scumball he's charismatic as
[ __ ] though i agree
and that's kind of like what's
interesting about
i mean i don't know it's like what's
like and i think i brought this up
before but like what is men or women
that i find like sexy
it doesn't always have to do with what
they look like sometimes it's like their
energy yeah you know what i mean with
him it was the way he carried himself
yeah that's like if you just looked at
him it's like he's he's kind of funny
looking but
he kind of had this
scumball energy to him but you but you
liked him you kind of feel a likeable
skill like a real life
another one that was kind of like that
was bruce dern he kind of was yeah but
he you kind of liked him yeah
there's a lot of actors like that yeah
there's probably like more actors like
that than
actresses that are like that because i
kind of feel like actresses up until
like recently unless you're like a
character actor
you know women had to look a certain way
but dudes could kind of look like
whatever
and you know yeah you you liked those
two dudes because you got to know them
through their roles yeah had a lot to do
with it
so it was like you were seeing somebody
that you knew
yeah they recognized you could recognize
them
you kind of kind of feel a sympathico
and uh as far as the
the sexy thing grantha's hammer also
says kate bush or bjork bjork bjork
um
kate bush is beautiful
but not sexy though bjork seems kind of
like sexy also kind of crazy
but in a hot way you know you know what
i mean i always liked her because she
was like kind of like a weirdo
so you know
i kind of i kind of like that uh i
thought debbie harry was dead no she's
not she's around yeah she's not last
time i saw her she was holding it
together too she still looked good
yeah i mean she know she doesn't look
like she did when she was a kid right
but like none of us do so
sheila anne says debbie is living in a
55 and over commuting in new jersey now
i feel old
[Laughter]
oh my god
uh did you also see grand theft auto
said i found some pics earlier today of
steve r and pat e from a backpacking
trip in a shoe box of old photos
full-size mullets and all reveal the
audience with stories of pat and steve
and the love hotel
they'll love him yeah yeah yeah i
already talked about that i thought you
talked about the level yeah talk about
ellen
that's right yeah
and his [ __ ] pathological line yeah
you know [ __ ] saw this party but
[ __ ]
boat hit it i jumped in and saved them
saved them all
i didn't tell that story but
maybe i shouldn't talk about a
[ __ ]
that's what i mean it's like sometimes
we say stuff of ballet people i'm always
just kind of like on the off chance that
one of them is actually like watching
this we're like oh man we're gonna get
big trouble steve is like what happened
yeah
we were you know drinking a few beers
and [ __ ] down the lake and
saw this party barge and got a speedboat
hit it [ __ ] cut it right in half
people started driving they were all
drunk i dropped i jumped in and saved
them i remember you telling me yeah how
did you save
like three or four
three or four
like you'd think if you'd save people's
lives you remember how many it was yeah
yeah yeah
i mean that would seem like it would
really kind of like you know i thought i
told you about that because i'm a
[ __ ] hero basically i've known you
your whole life man you never told me
that yeah it was like four or five years
ago it's because i'm saying i'm modest
and it's like i just never thought to
bring it up so you were how old when
this happened that mean you were like 13
you
yeah yeah i was probably about 13. yeah
yeah yeah
yeah that would be 15.
oh my god seriously yeah
i mean that's crazy yeah graham cause i
doubt pat's watching yeah
i mean yeah i i kind of like don't worry
about it i mean obviously the more
drinks i have the less i worry about it
but i do kind of think of it sometimes
like at random like the next day and i'm
like oh [ __ ] did we say something like
really bad about somebody in there yeah
i don't think like because i kind of
feel like other than i mean other than
you guys but probably like people that
maybe know us in real life
i'm i kind of feel like they probably
see enough of us in real life they don't
really need to like watch more hours
of us
[Laughter]
they're like yeah we have enough of
y'all [ __ ] in real life no
that's not what it is it's the same
thing because they do they do stuff in
public for living too some of them are
[ __ ] belly dancers and dancers and
uh
we don't watch their [ __ ] either some of
them are porn stars we don't watch their
[ __ ]
yeah
you know because it's that's not the
person that you know
you know i'm from how you know i'm at
the clubs and you don't really care what
they do for a living
yeah that's true so it's more about i
mean we have gone and seen like you know
we have friends that have bands and yeah
we'll see that [ __ ] like that and we do
and we go see that or like you know yeah
but we're not watching all their
interviews and stuff that they're having
yeah that's true
cause it's like yeah i know that
[ __ ] yeah
we know him we don't need to watch this
you know it's not like we're watching
all the mary lynn's stuff you know i
don't think i only saw like a couple of
maryland's movies i saw that last one
you know the [ __ ] one with the time
travel oh that's right what the hell was
that one called i forgot it's on netflix
yeah that netflix one um
had all the it was a good movie
yeah it was pretty good
although i mean i remember it being good
it did i mean it was one of those ones
that was like a big spectacle one and
you're like yeah that was pretty good
but i don't really remember much about
it yeah and she does a lot of stand-up
stuff i don't watch any of that
yeah
to be honest she'll be on um
a couple i guess about a week ago she
was on um
um
instagram she was live streaming talking
to all her friends and i jump in there
and start [ __ ] trolling her and we
started talking about [ __ ] old times
for a while she told everybody who i was
only for a few minutes and i just let
her get back to work because you know
we came up together we all came together
in drama man you know that we know how
to [ __ ] play off of one another
well plus if you hung out in there too
long and you were kind of like then it
would be kind of weird yeah no yeah
for a few minutes and [ __ ] fire up
the crowd and [ __ ] say something to
her and give her to give her a chance to
[ __ ] have a witty response and went
back and forth for a little bit and i
checked out
you know which is that's actually the
professional thing to do you know so
everybody helps you know i'll
i'll jump into the live stream on
[ __ ] um
uh uh other youtubers that [ __ ] i
like and [ __ ] and fire up the crowd and
[ __ ] make money for them hey you know
like uh
oh [ __ ] uh who was that that i did for
did that for the other day
um
empress [ __ ] um
joy jean judging yeah you know jumped in
there and said she never asked for money
uh you know it says this is this poor
girl [ __ ] is not monetizing she never
asks for buddy she just does this [ __ ]
basically for free and then boom boom
boom boom boom she had like two
100
super chats and like a couple of 30
super chats right after that then later
after the show she [ __ ] just thank
you for doing that that was you know
because uh that's her only source of
income is the occasional live stream and
she only live streams like once a month
she's cute as [ __ ] she's just real
humble she's afraid to live stream and
afraid to make money
i get the afraid to live stream because
i didn't really want to do it either at
first because remember you guys we never
live streamed we recorded everything
until
our 200th episode right yeah i think the
200th episode we're like oh it's gonna
be a big deal so we're actually gonna do
a live stream and i was like i was like
really nervous about it but the more we
do it it's like now yeah i like this
actually better i just it's less
stressful
doing a live stream than it is recording
it which is stupid because i mean when
i'm recording something like a book
review or a movie or if i [ __ ] something
up obviously i can just like edit it out
and i can't do that like on a live
stream but i don't know why
i don't know i guess because most of the
stuff that i record
um when it's just me
i always kind of feel like well i don't
have
you know i don't have you to talk to or
i don't have the chat to talk to so i'm
always kind of like you know what if i
just like sit there and go duh or i
sound really dumb or something like that
so i don't know i just i just have like
a lot of issues like that
but still even after all this time
joy jean lives in uh nigeria she's got
an office job that's that's that's
that's and she has what would be
considered to be a good office job in
nigeria
which is i think she told me it was it
was like less than 300 bucks a month
that's what she makes
and she could [ __ ] pull down she
could pull down four or five hundred
bucks a month or flat four or five
hundred bucks a week just in super
chatting that's what i told her just
just in live streaming and that actually
scared her
because that was just that whole dynamic
you know what i mean she just wasn't
ready for this she says oh no because
the idea of making money on the internet
more than what you'd make from hard work
kind of ups
kind of
scared her in a way well i don't even
know if it's that i just i kind of think
if i mean if she has like the same kind
of mindset that i have it's almost kind
of like
um
who the [ __ ] would pay to listen to my
stupid ass back every time she goes on
there she makes better that's what i
mean but it's like
it's hard to get out of that mindset
yeah that's what i'm trying to tell you
yeah
um you know for somebody like me and she
might be the same where it's just kind
of like what you know why would anybody
want to do that it's like why did but
then it's like i think about that and i
still think about that even like i said
even when i'm like recording my videos
like uh you know reviewing books and
movies and stuff and i'm always just
kind of like why the [ __ ] would anybody
care like what i think about this movie
or what i think about this book or
whatever and then i'm just but then i'll
watch like some other horror channels
and some other horror channels it's
usually dudes and they have like a lot
more followers then i'm like well this
dude's kind of lame though and it's like
you know he's just kind of sitting there
going uh well blah blah it's like some
of them are good uh you know i'm not
naming anybody or anything but um you
know some of them i'm like well
i think mine are better than that so i
guess i can't be that bad you know what
i'm saying you know so it's it's i don't
know it's just hard that's all yeah um
lee warner says what do you think about
robert eggers remaking nosferatu you
know what
uh i hadn't heard about that crazily but
that cut that sounds really intriguing
actually robert eggers made the
lighthouse and he also made the witch
which i don't think you saw but it's
amazing
um probably pretty good so i'm like yeah
that's [ __ ] good
i'm down and it's like and i kind of
feel like robert eggers he's the kind of
[ __ ] because you didn't see the
witch that came out in 2016. and it was
set in i can't remember what year it was
set in but it said like back in old like
witchcraft times you know what i mean
and he like got all of the all of the uh
english correct he got all of the
costuming exactly right like he got
everything like and sewn and everything
like that so he's like a real stickler
for everything being period appropriate
so i kind of feel like he'd be the kind
of [ __ ] that he if he's making
nosferatu he would kind of make it like
a silent movie and i am so down i mean
that sounds really cool if it's a silent
movie it'll bomb i mean not necessarily
like a silent movie but make it like
look like a silent movie you know what i
mean yeah well yeah but it's like you
know well
it sounds like
i'm thinking that it has to be in black
and white that's what i was going to say
yeah i mean yeah the last movie was
yeah i mean the last time somebody uh
because somebody brought up i think on
the um on the last live stream that we
did somebody brought up the movie
begotten which was from the 90s
and that was a silent movie uh it was
made in the 90s like i said but they but
he tried to make it look like it's the
same guy that did shadow of the vampire
um which was about the making of nice
ferrari so
um but he tried to make it look like an
old like silent movie and that [ __ ] was
like disturbing as [ __ ] it was like a it
was like a nightmare you know what i
mean
so you can't do it but obviously
making it a silent film sure that's
gonna uh you know significantly shrink
your audience but i kind of feel like
robert eggers he has enough
at least critical cred
and horror movie
geek cred
to maybe kind of do what he wants but i
don't know we'll see
i mean it doesn't have to be well
because you know they made the they made
the one with uh klaus kinski
he made that in the seven no no no i'm
just saying they made they did a
nosferatu
in the in the seventies with cansky in
it it was good and that was you know
that wasn't silent yeah it was okay that
one right there yeah the one with them
that is my favorite absolute favorite
poster like movie poster of all time i
love that poster so much
somebody messaged me the other day and
said i've meant to tell you this for a
long time but that nosferatu poster back
there like kicks ass yeah i was like
doesn't it though i think i got that in
the uk actually but that's like that was
a good portrayal of nosferatu and we
were talking about klaus kinski we
talked about him on the uh when we were
talking about on the flesh for
frankenstein review which i posted
earlier today and um yeah klaus kensky
he just always struck me as like really
really creepy
really creepy
he's a pervert
yeah it's like i don't know if he
actually was like in real life but he
just seemed seems like a pervert to me
i mean i still i still have yet to see
everything like everybody keeps telling
me you have to see the documentary my
best fiend which was werner herzog
uh you know because he had a
long working relationship slash
friendship slash frenemy type of thing
going with klaus kinski for like many
years
and um and he made the documentary about
klaus kinski called my best fiend and i
told you too when i was talking about
when i was talking about crawl space
which i reviewed
uh the
the behind the scenes [ __ ] on that they
made a documentary but it's not long i
think it's only like 10 minutes but the
director of that made a documentary
called please kill mr kinski
because everybody on the set hated him
so much because he was so [ __ ]
difficult and
and people were like pretty much
out right right in front of his face
like calling for his death like on the
set of that movie because it was just
they couldn't take it anymore and uh
yeah it's pretty entertaining actually
the movie's pretty entertaining too but
i just think that's so funny that people
are just like right in front of his face
we're like please kill him please kill
him you know i mean it's like that's
very very funny
david june says what's up freaks hey
uh camp guy says that vampire movie with
martin landau
and johnny depp was good just keep
talking there was no vampire movie
are you talking about ed wood that's
something he could be talking about
and would play [ __ ] yeah that was
that wasn't a vampire but well yeah i
mean technically i wasn't a vampire
maybe that was like
i mean martin landau that was one of
only two movies that i can think of that
had an actor playing like a real person
yeah that i forgot that that wasn't the
real person martin landau playing villa
lugosi in that i totally forgot that
bella lucas it was you know it was not
that was uh not with us anymore i was
going to say bella because he's dead but
then everybody's gonna make like the
bauhaus reference and then i just did it
anyway but uh yeah so i totally forgot
the only other one that i can think of
like that was uh charlize theron in
monster
where she played alien warnos i went and
saw that in the theater
and
while i was watching it i totally forgot
that alienwareness was dead and that
that wasn't her
you know what i mean it looked just like
a i mean
she just she [ __ ] embodied that role
she can act
holy [ __ ] she's amazing
i mean she's good in pretty much
everything i've seen her in
but you know
it's it's [ __ ] crazy it's just
[ __ ] crazy how good she was in that i
need to see that again actually
now that i'm thinking about it grandpa's
hammer said the mermaid in the
lighthouse was totally hot until she
started screeching i don't remember that
i just remembered a carved figure of one
that he jerked off too yeah that's
something i remember there was a there
was a uh
a mermaid in that
yeah well
yeah i think so
although i think it was just like in his
imagination wasn't it yeah yeah
yeah i said maybe i mixed up ed wood and
shadow the vampire yeah shadow of the
vampire had
willem dafoe
um
and playing max shrek
and
uh
what's his name
john malkovich playing fw mernau
i just rewatched that again the other
day and it's that still holds up that's
kind of like that's about the making of
nosferatu like back from the 20s i think
eddie is art is in that too now that i'm
thinking about it um but yeah it's like
it's kind of like a dark comedy but the
whole
but
sort of
and the whole premise of it is that max
shrek the guy that played nosferatu in
the original movie was actually a
vampire and that fw morneau was like so
um was so into like making this the most
realistic movie ever that he actually
like scoured the earth and found an
actual vampire to put in the movie but
yeah it's awesome
uh sylvester stallone wrote a script for
edgar allan poe i always wanted to see
sly make this as well as play him
it would be a shame if he never made it
so he's wants to play edgar allan poe
i mean i think he's too old for that now
obviously because edgar allan poe died
when he was pretty young
but
uh
i don't know
i don't know if that would have worked
even when he was younger
i wouldn't mind seeing jeffrey combs as
uh edgar allan poe stuff that he does
live on stage
yeah cause he yeah he had like kind of a
long running well they might it might be
on youtube or something somewhere yeah
yeah because he kind of had a long
running like stage show yeah where he
played edgar allan poe yeah and he'd
read his poems and
i've seen bits of it yeah there was
i think there's a whole like uh
monologues that go along with it in
there
yeah yeah i mean he just i think he
reads some of the stories and because
edgar allan poe didn't just write horror
you know right he wrote like uh comedy
he wrote literary criticism he wrote all
kind of stuff yeah the comments was
doing the horror yeah well yeah because
that's kind of what everybody's right
i mean yeah
let's let's be fair
and uh
somebody mentioned being john malkovich
yeah that's a great [ __ ] movie i
haven't seen that in a long time either
murder hornet says alien mortis was hot
as [ __ ]
i saw a real interview with alien wernos
um
in the interview she came across this
really really touched in the head yeah
lots of psychotic ideations yeah i got
that impression as well thank you zack
it's also weird how there are singers
who can't act and vice versa same with
models who try acting and can't even
though they're all professions that use
similar skills
yes but similar doesn't mean exactly the
same you know
because i've known some people that were
in bands
they didn't always get their jobs the
same way either yeah and i don't think
that they would be good because i could
see myself being like in a band but i
don't i don't think i would be a very
good actor yeah because i'm just not
good at like faking being somebody else
just because a model was a good model
doesn't mean they can act i mean must be
let's be honest [ __ ] most models were
hookers
that's what they are
if a rich guy wants to [ __ ] get laid
he's a celebrity he doesn't go to the
brothel he goes down the modeling agency
that's what he does
yeah sorry to break your [ __ ] heart
but uh and then you're sure and that
one's hard yeah so
then they try to put those in the damn
movies and you just put yeah but the
thing is there's a
kind of a lot of actresses you know
same kind of deal
the ones that ended up in the movies are
the ones that got casted properly on the
damn couch
and that's how they got that movie and
then they got to sleep with other dudes
[ __ ] uh producers and [ __ ] to get
certain movies made
the whole why that old tale that yeah
you know
back to even all the way back to the
hollywood silver screen that yeah
actresses are prostitutes
yeah they are they are
most of them
and uh that goes back to the damn
[ __ ] 1800s brothels a thing that was
called a star
you had hookers in those pro in those
brothels
but they didn't want to be known for
that so they would get up there and sing
and dance and they would and they and
they would get famous in front of the
clients
and they would put their face inside a
star and they called them stars and then
their rates could could go up too
because they were talented it was a
hooker that had talent
and hollywood adopted that model don't
let anybody ever tell you otherwise
that's what they are
and i believe that most of the guys are
too uh
and
come on
i mean you know [ __ ] corey feldman
tried to warn everybody
he's [ __ ] that's right that's true
that's how it is
a lot of those guys that came up [ __ ]
young [ __ ]
in the 80s you know
you know [ __ ] went down that's how they
get like getting in those movies
that booty's worth money
they want a million dollar job they're
gonna have to earn it because acting
anybody can act
that's the way they look at it
and a lot of [ __ ] whistleblowers to
come out of that scene and go yeah
that's exactly what it is it was the
same thing with a lot of them uh um
there were some of those
damn uh uh
[ __ ] kind of like instant pop star
chicks
they'd uh get high up in the damn
this is we're talking about mostly in
the 90s just when some of this [ __ ] was
coming out the sony music could run them
they'd make millions of dollars but
really uh on the side they had to
[ __ ] do things
to make money
that whole [ __ ] business is bad man
the whole business you know it's
[ __ ] prostitution
well like you said i think that it comes
from i mean they have so many people
that want to do it that want to be
famous you know that they're just kind
of like well if you don't want to do it
then we can somebody else like 100 other
people that well right so the people
that are in charge of these people that
gain power in hollywood are these
weinstein type dudes like well yeah if
you want this roll and make 5 million 10
million dollars you're gonna have to
blow me
or blow my friend because he just paid
me to 2 million now you don't need this
it's [ __ ] corrupt as [ __ ]
captain blairdo says if brook shields
ever became a messed out zombie people
would call her the creature from the
blue lagoon
then camp guy says uh eric bogosian is a
great monologue guy yeah he is he had a
show kind of like sterling gray i
remember seeing the sterling gray one
like on cable back in the 80s and eric
bogosian i remember he was in that movie
talk radio
which was about it was like based on a
true story like about that radio dj who
was kind of like a shock jock type thing
and he got like essentially like
assassinated like somebody like he had a
stalker and that and killed him
um i need to see that again actually i
haven't said that i saw that in cable
background sparks and corey's right and
then they're talking about cory heym too
yeah
now corey hayne was the one that died
right because i know one of the cory's
corey haim died corey feldman still it
was
am i did i get him corey feldman was
also warning people though wasn't he
or am i did i get him did they get him
mixed up oh i don't know i don't really
i think i thought yeah i thought um
yeah it goes back to [ __ ] oh michael
jackson in the damn [ __ ] house with
the damn [ __ ] amusement park out in
front of it okay
old school celebrity had unwarranted
power
uh there weren't
there was only 13 channels on the
television you had [ __ ] a couple of
movie studios
and you had cable tv there was no
internet
people become enamored with what they
saw on the screen
and uh those guys would abuse their
[ __ ] power and if you wanted to
become one of those celebrities you it
would it was not on the back of talent
talent was very very common
you had to go above and beyond to
[ __ ] join
you had to be marketable you had to have
more marketable skills they're talking
about is booty
okay
you are going to become a [ __ ]
expensive piece of booty
and from that movie from that from that
booty you could generate enough money to
finance the production of movies too
so kind of is a high high class hooker
male and female
now not all
but i think most
not all of them though
which makes this brings me back to
[ __ ] tom i do not believe tom cruise
was gay
but it would not but tom came from
nothing most of those people came from
nothing it would not surprise me if they
abused tom
all right which that's what left him
vulnerable for [ __ ] scientology to
[ __ ] take advantage of it
there's some compensation over
compensation in in in tom cruise and and
he always saying that scientology helped
him what they help him with
maybe it was to overcome abuse
maybe
although that seems like trading one
form of abuse for another although i
guess the scientologist treated him
better than they treated me with other
people but still would not surprise me
if tom was abused
jason says judy garland was work to
death at a young age yeah i kind of feel
like even when she was a teenager
um her big thing was her weight so they
put her on all these drugs like to keep
her for getting fat yeah and she got
addicted to him yeah in the end so
they're all kind of like terrible
stories from back in the day
hollywood of the silver screen when it
first started to when the hollywood that
you know started to be uh started to be
born
back a long time ago out in california
it was real closely associated with like
the carnival it was like cardi's it's
like that
it's all an illusion
well i mean uh glamour was not really
what you think well it was all a veneer
i mean there was a lot of stuff going on
and i wrote about some of the cases in
uh in my book where they talked about
like you know [ __ ] that happened in the
20s and 30s you had people that were big
stars like in the silent era and a
little bit later um who got [ __ ]
murdered and [ __ ] like that and like the
studios were so powerful that they would
like cover that [ __ ] up yeah the studios
controlled the police
yeah they're well you know or at least
they'd be kind of like let's uh kind of
clean up the crime scene like before the
cops get here and like the cops knew
right so they did a lot of kind of it's
really easy to pay off a [ __ ] chief
chief of police if you send him a little
starlet every now and then you get
whatever you want [ __ ] are
crooked especially back in those days
even today i don't think it's changed i
think it's the same
it's just that uh
luckily if you ask me this the power of
the studio system is waning because like
i said that's the only game in town
that's why i don't really complain about
it because it was just as bad back then
or worse and it was worse it was worse
because nobody knew about it really um
because they were really good at like
keeping [ __ ] clamped down and now it'll
usually it'll come out eventually yeah
and california was uh a [ __ ] bad
scene back in the in the era of the
silver screen the 20s and the 30s you'd
have [ __ ]
extreme
wealth right along extreme poverty and
those starlets came from extreme poverty
uh they just were good-looking
and and you weren't going to get that
job unless you were willing to play ball
they had a lot of power over them
sad i mean even [ __ ] what is his name
errol flynn and [ __ ] what do you didn't
he buy a 13 year old girl and keep her
as a sex slave yeah i think he did
actually i mean you know if i might be
remembering that wrong but yeah that
sounds like something he had a room made
for that had a two-way mirror above
there and his buddies would go up in the
attic and he'd they'd all watch each
other [ __ ] her
weird [ __ ]
and then he'd snort a bunch of cocaine
and go out on a boat with these underage
girls and [ __ ]
good restaurant
yeah so like i said it's not uh nothing
new people were doing all kind of
horrible [ __ ] back then you just didn't
they just didn't find out about it until
like a lot later
uh yeah grampur sammer said when i lived
in oregon we used to go to winnemucca
winamooca okay nevada
to drink and gamble the brothels were
always full of truck drivers using i80
poor girls there's nothing nastier than
a long-haul trucker right it's
i can't imagine it's you know what i
mean i can't imagine like
that being your only [ __ ] career
option you know what i mean and i know
it does happen and i know sometimes you
know
poverty drug addiction whatever but it's
just kind of like holy crap man
it's [ __ ] horrifying in a way like i
said i kind of wish that
they would
legalize it and regulate it in the same
way that you know parts of nevada do
because i do kind of feel like at least
then
you'd get people that actually like went
there like went to the brothel to get a
job and kind of knew what they were in
for rather than just taking
you know just doing it out of
desperation which like seems really
really sad because i know there are some
people that
would would do that like
you know and there's nothing wrong with
that if that's how you want to make
money out of some [ __ ] man
i'm not judging i'm just saying
that it's like it would be nice if that
was just like another option that you
had that you didn't like have to fall
into that because that's all you had
left yeah cocaine's a hell of a drug
yeah somebody's talking about roman
polanski yeah
it's just kind of like
i don't know i just kind of feel like
i don't
maybe
i don't know i kind of feel like
everybody kind of sucks maybe maybe it's
just kind of like hollywood you hear
about that because everybody's famous
and stuff but
regular people are shitty too regular
people do shitty stuff like that all the
time
maybe you just don't hear about it as
much because they're not famous
jason says robert stack did some
interviews on youtube about lana turner
and judy garland he said they wanted to
keep judy young while uh lana was more
desirable yeah i mean the [ __ ] they did
to judy garland was just like terrible
if you guys have ever read um what was
that famous book that came back back in
the old days hollywood babylon
i think they did a couple like vert like
a
sequel for that or something like that i
remember reading those a while back now
some of the stuff in there is [ __ ]
and exaggerated and it just kind of goes
on gossips and they don't really have
any proof for it and stuff but there's
enough stuff in there that's been backed
up by evidence that's that's you know
horrifying enough i was but i was saying
too that
you know people just regular ass people
do shitty stuff too it's just that you
don't hear about it as much because
they're not famous so it might be
kind of a little bit of that going on
too you know what i'm saying
we're drinking uh smirnoff citrus vodka
which is lemon flavor
and iced tea
that i made it's pretty good yeah we
just had the idea today we had to go
down to
the liquor store yeah and the publix
and he's walking to the liquor store i
went in the publix because i had to get
cat treats
and uh because pookie was like freaking
out there's only one box left this is
[ __ ] so we had to go get some more
and so he's going in there and he's like
oh i'm going to get some citrus vibe
like some lemon or something yeah
and apparently he asked the guy that
works in the liquor store
uh you know is this good with iced tea
and indeed it is yeah i mean i guess
it's citrus it's but is it just lemon or
does it have like grapefruit or
something there's lemons it just lemon
on the bottle
that's great
because it doesn't really taste all that
i know they have like grapefruit vodka
which actually
i like i like grapefruit vodka
but it's one of those ones i like lemon
vodka too
but
i can't drink too much of it because
it's really like acidic and after a
while it'll start making me like go
you know what i mean like i'll kind of
feel nauseated because it's just so
acid i wonder tina's gonna show up
tonight i don't know i haven't got a
message today she usually shows up when
she gets home from work
and she's been coming home i think
[ __ ] uh
probably around seven o'clock our time
uh last time she came yeah cause that's
right she's in a different what time is
she okay so she's like three hours
tammy says shirley temple has said ben
would come onto her when she was little
that does not surprise you yeah
honestly you know what and and i kind of
feel like most
women when they were younger girls
um have stories like that where they
have like some creepy like 45 year old
dude like hitting on you when you're
like [ __ ] 10.
most girls i know have a story like that
yeah uh because
uh some of those dudes are [ __ ] gross
and they will totally totally hit on
like a a child
you know there's more of them than you
think there are i've read commentary on
shirley temple though they say that um
shirley temple the way she was filmed
and the effects that they did and the
acts that they had around is that she's
being portrayed as an adult sex symbol
yeah and if you watch some of that stuff
it's kind of weird yeah
and uh that evidently there were a lot
of guys of that generation that were
kind of like had a huge crush on this
seven-year-old six seven-year-old girl
yeah which and they kind of
if you go back you go back and you look
at
30s
entertainment like you know our gang or
little rascals
they had a lot of [ __ ] stuff between
generations that would be real
inappropriate like
you know
spanky and alfalfa competing for the
love of [ __ ] miss crabtree the the
the uh the uh the teacher
yeah she's probably about 20
and they're coming on to her and she's
like oh really and she's kind of like
she's hamming it up right but evidently
that was just part of the culture they
did they had a childhood per se
in the 30s
they didn't have
teenagers in the 30s i kind of feel like
that was more like a post-war like a
post-world war ii invention 50s like a
like a separate period between childhood
and adulthood yeah you know if you could
walk and talk then you were old enough
to drink and smoke cigarettes
they were like that they were working
yes well not if they were like five but
you know what i mean
uh well now someone well no because yeah
some kids were working in coal mine they
weren't so much they were working at
factories and stuff in england
if you could walk and talk and do a job
then a lot of them were working uh
what you were seeing in in our gang was
like uh the very be just california that
2030s that was the very beginnings of
kind of like modern america where there
was childhood
back in europe those [ __ ] were
[ __ ] working
in a coal mine
and they're like hey they're [ __ ]
small they can fit down yeah right
but there's a lot of
a lot of arguments against the way we do
it now you know we're having like
extended childhoods way into their 30s
and stuff
and then
when you analyze what they teach in
school and even what they taught our
generation in school a lot of it was
[ __ ]
and then when you look at the way the
laws are set up a lot of it had to do
with was protecting adult jobs from
children or younger people
uh what i'm talking about is this
if you actually looked at the
your average education public education
in the united states
by the time you got to like your
sophomore year you really the average
person really didn't learn much more
than that
okay you you really could cut them loose
in the 10th grade
um
you probably could probably handle your
average entry-level job by the time the
10th grade came out
because a lot of i mean a lot of kids i
went to high school with had jobs i
already had jobs right you know but the
laws were set up labor laws were mostly
set up because adults did not want to
compete against a younger
uh person entering in the job market
that would work for less because it was
depressing
the
the wages for labor
and then they started to change the
education system to make all high school
education oriented towards sending a kid
to college
uh but that was done in a time when the
united states was hurting for college
level people
it was
probably a bad idea what they should
have done is is they should have
you should have been graduating from
high school by around 10th grade
if you were gifted
intellectually
you should have
been groomed to go to
college
that's kind of how they do it in the uk
that's why it should if you're not
uh scholastically gifted you should be
sent to trade schools yeah that's what
they do these things how to build things
you go i mean for as far as i
am aware that they still do it like this
you go to school until you're 16
um and then they have you on different
tracks so it's like if you
aren't really like into college or you
don't want to do that then you go to
like a year or two year trade school
and they teach you whatever like you
know building or whatever the hell and
but if you want to go on to college then
you do another two years of high school
and then go to university what happened
something like that because they had the
laws set up that way
banks and universities saw a big
opportunity to make a bunch of money
to uh sell everybody
some kind of [ __ ] degree
well if you have to sell everybody a
degree you have to water it down because
most people aren't going to be needed
you don't need degrees to run a society
you need workers you need a lot more
indians than you need chiefs
so most of the stuff that they are
teaching people in these universities is
something along the lines something
that's not useful you know underwater
basket weaving uh [ __ ] minute women's
studies social studies [ __ ] it
doesn't really do anything
not for the person that's learning it
and not really much for it's not really
doing anything for society what it's
doing is it's like in giving a bank an
opportunity to make a loan and it's
giving a university the opportunity to
make some money
so it's a scam all right but i mean the
thing about it though is that there's
tons of community colleges
that do year or two year just like
certificate programs
you know where you get they're not
legalized
well yeah
i mean there were tons of people at the
one i went to
where they teach you more like technical
type things they teach you to like how
to do like air conditioning repair yeah
mechanics or something like that trade
school in mississippi yeah i mean it's
but it's the same thing it's a community
college and really uh
had they gone to trade schooling
uh would have a lot more say uh human
satisfaction because of far more demand
for it you can make a lot more money uh
it doesn't take as long to get trained
in that and you'll be active and you can
go back and retrain for other things as
the market changes it's a lot more
flexible well i mean that's the way to
go what they had with the school that i
went to which actually is not a
community college anymore because they
upped their uh thing and now it's like a
state college but what they would do is
they would have one year or two year
they had like a one-year certificate
program for various um you know kind of
like technical type things like you know
air conditioning repair or mechanics or
something like that
yeah plumbing stuff like that you could
get a one-year certificate for and
actually it was only like nine months or
whatever and it was like really cheap um
they also had two-year associates
degrees in you know kind of like you
know business admin graphic design stuff
like that um and then what they would do
is there was another there was a
university part of which was on the same
campus so you could do two years of for
example graphic design if you wanted to
finish up your bachelor's degree then
you could transfer all of those credits
and then you could just go you know for
a shorter time and you would get a
bachelor's degree in the same kind of
thing but most of the people that went
were doing kind of just more trade
school type things you know what i mean
they should have done that but you know
what i mean it was you had bad
leadership and lots of corruption in the
united states and they just wanted to
push it in a way they could make the
most money
and the easy way the easiest way to make
money is to exploit human weakness and
one of the human weaknesses is the quest
for status
so you tell people that if you go to
these universities and learn this kind
of [ __ ] thing you'll have all this
status you'll end up in the ruling class
that's not what happened what happened
is it just
it just kind of diluted the value
of a [ __ ] college degree because
everybody has them and half of them are
damn full of [ __ ]
worthless you know what you really want
is you want
workers people that skilled labor
uh that can create and make things
people are happier doing that
um and they make more money doing that
like the example nobody wants to [ __ ]
live in a house that's filled with [ __ ]
coming out of the damn pipes people will
pay anything to have somebody come and
[ __ ] fix down pipes and keep the [ __ ]
from flowing into the damn house me and
jenny fought that one time the [ __ ]
stuff coming up out of the damn toilet
for how desperate it is you're like damn
the toilet water coming up plumbing is
[ __ ] very important
all right now people will look down
their nose at a damn plumber but if you
look at the bottom line and you look at
the cost versus reward involved between
a doctor and a plumber that plumber is
actually doing better than your average
doctor well i mean everybody gets to
until [ __ ] coming out of your toilet
right you know what i'm saying so apply
for your ac breaks in florida in august
plumbers
plumber does not have the debt that a
doctor has and does not have the
overheads they don't work the hours that
a [ __ ] doctor has but his profits are
[ __ ] greater than doc than a doctor
he doesn't have the status for some
strange reason but that's society well
they also don't have as much debt as
doctors have because they pale yeah they
already have a lot of debt
looked at that [ __ ]
the actual profit margin
all right especially when doctors do
make a lot of money and the plumber is
actually winning
and but for some reason he does not have
the social [ __ ] status which is some
stupid [ __ ] doctors do make a lot of
money though especially but they spend a
lot of money especially if they're
special and then they're not around yeah
that is true but i said the average
though yeah average the ones that are
really making big money evidently are
surgeons or people like
my friend dr matt
he owns the [ __ ] orlando hospital his
his mom built that orlando general and
really what he has is he hires doctors
to down work in the hospital then
that's the way
that that's where you're
hiring factories and whole armies of
doctors that's really where the money is
well i mean you being a practitioner
it's being it's somebody inside well
that's kind of where that's true that's
true of any uh trade or any job right
you want to be the person boss and all
the other [ __ ] around
you make a lot more money than you
actually like doing the actual work
but he doesn't have to practice i mean
a graphic designer makes less than an
art director even though
essentially the art director just comes
up with the idea and is like now you
guys do it right exactly you know what i
mean
and all make like twice as much as you
right bitter oh attached right and
then another thing the way they got us
set up because of just basically human
human frailties and corruption
you would think
the smartest [ __ ] in the world
would and i you know living out i lived
outside boston somerville for a while
[ __ ] new mit students and harvard
students
smartest [ __ ] were there were
the mit students and it was just pure
science god they were annoying you just
couldn't be around them they were they
were so [ __ ] nerdy and geeky
those dudes wouldn't hardly make any
money
they wouldn't make any money
the best minds
that entered into the system weren't
going into science because of the money
they were smart enough to go chase the
money guess where they were going
finance
the smartest [ __ ] were not
going into signs they were going into
finance
because then they could work in the
banking system
and they just printed money they printed
money for them they worked for the
companies that printed money they're
working at the federal reserve bank
you know
money printing [ __ ] that's
where they're
because why wouldn't you do
that why wouldn't maybe you don't want
your own success
not damn go go go try to reason with
them well no i'm just saying that you
guys are going no i'm gonna i mean go
where the money is probably the people
that went to mit they were like super
into science and they just wanted to do
something like that so it's a trade-off
you don't want to like spend you don't
want to spend your whole life in a
career that you're going to spend 30 40
50 years of your life doing and it makes
you miserable
even if you make a lot of money at it
sometimes for some people it's not worth
it a lot of those guys though they end
up in the financial [ __ ] industries
they don't really do the work per se
it's more like joining a cult
you know they get positions so they all
know each other and like yeah they they
know how to invent financial mechanisms
on paper to get certain things done but
then they spend the rest of the time
down on yachts
and private islands
you know which that's probably the
smarter way to go although some dudes
like the mit dudes that i'd run into is
annoying and [ __ ]
crazy as they were
they're kind of like dudes that are
[ __ ] would geek out of comic books or
video games they were totally into that
[ __ ]
but really when you analyzed what they
ended up doing and what they were ended
up using for they were just employees
which uh the real [ __ ] alpha
[ __ ] never wants to be an
employee
they want to be a potent tate
granthar's hammer said do they still
have charm schools for women in the
south
it uh
no although it wouldn't shock me if
there was one like in some corner
somewhere
i honestly a few years back this is
probably like five or ten years ago i
remember reading an article
about it i'm in the north though it's
called wellesley college go ahead
thank you
um i remember reading an article like
five or ten years ago about uh a
cotillion
in atlanta
and it was like recent and i was just
kind of like holy [ __ ] are they still
doing that
are we back in like gone with the wind
days i thought those went out in like
the [ __ ] 1960s
i guess not i guess they still do them
somewhere i don't know that was like a
few years back so i don't really want
the street from wellesley college and
that's in wellesley massachusetts
uh hillary clinton went there it was all
girls [ __ ] school we used to [ __ ]
call it the dike dungeon and they called
it the dike dungeon
super expensive school
danny rolling ghostface says uh you
should totally do a show on infamous
necrophiliacs grave body robbers we
actually did do a necrophilia one like a
long time ago it was the only show and
it still makes me laugh to this day that
tom was so disgusted that he like took
off at the end of the show
um
especially about funeral home female
necrophiliac karen greenlee now we
didn't talk about her we did talk about
who the [ __ ] did we talk about on that
show
we talked about the guy that dug up his
uh that well it wasn't his girlfriend it
was a young girl it was a young girl
that he was like obsessed with and he
just dug up he didn't kill her but he
like dug up her body and kept it and
that was super gross and
oh [ __ ] who's that other was that dude's
name carl something uh
yeah i'll think of it like in 15 minutes
from now and i'll just be like oh
but yeah we did one a while back but i i
was
very amused at how disgusted tom was so
of course so of course i had to keep
like poking yeah
because i think it's gross too but it
doesn't bother me as much i guess it
really bothers me
i mean it bothers me but i've read so
much like disgusting horror fiction and
true crime and stuff that it's like
nothing really phases me anymore so i'm
just i'm not bothered by it
um
let's see
[Music]
mr roboto says there are charm schools
for teenagers jenny okay
like i said i
it wouldn't shock me if there were some
i kind of feel like i don't think they
call them charm schools i think they
call them finishing schools yeah where
they teach you stuff like how you're
supposed to walk properly and how to
like dress and like manners and [ __ ]
like that it was home skills
that was [ __ ] like that yeah how to make
dresses how to how to uh cook
well that's no that's more homex [ __ ]
that's more homemade
did they i kind of i thought that was
more just kind of like a social
etiquette type of
uh how to throw parties
yeah i thought it was more that kind of
stuff like party hosting and [ __ ] where
i kind of feel like home eck it's funny
i was just reading uh an article the
other day about homet classes
and uh they still have them at some high
schools i think they still do home back
and shop and all that and i took comec
and shop
actually i took him in junior high not
high school
um
but it was kind of like
it was one of those things where it was
like four
uh each semester was something else so
you have like a semester of shop a
semester of homek a semester of
uh like kind of graphics like
photography and you know like linoleum
carving and [ __ ] like that
and then
what was the other one was it health
[ __ ] i can't remember what the fourth
one was but the homet class
we did because i was kind of interested
to see like what other people's like
because people from all over the us were
talking about what their home at classes
like what they had taught in them and
some people had like a whole year of
home back and they're like yeah we did
like one semester sewing and one
semester cooking and ones with like some
other [ __ ] or whatever i kind of feel
like ours was only one semester which
was nine weeks and we did
it was mostly cooking and sewing i
mostly remember
the cooking we did do make a lot of [ __ ]
like we made
grape jelly
we made
crepe souzette of all things um yeah we
had the crepe maker and everything uh we
made like a lot of baked stuff
lasagna do we make lasagna so we did
make a bunch of [ __ ] and then we had
sewing and i was [ __ ] hopeless at
that we had to make a pair of shorts
and mine just came out
i think i had to throw them away
i just couldn't get the hang of it i can
sew by hand
uh if i have to like i can sew on a
button and [ __ ] like that but
making like an article i probably could
if i applied myself to it but
i mean nowadays my vision's kind of bad
and it's just like too fiddly so i'd
probably be like i wouldn't have the
patience but even back then i didn't
really have the patience for it i was
okay at the cooking and all that stuff
but the sewing i was just kind of like
[ __ ] this man i don't want to [ __ ] do
this
but so i actually really am because my
mom
uh could sew anything
she made clothes for me she made
halloween costumes she made clothes for
other people and she really liked it
like she really enjoyed it and i so i
kind of wanted a little bit of that like
i could do
you know kind of [ __ ] stuff like
macrame and latch hook and that kind of
stuff you know cross stitch
but
making an entire pair of shorts that
kind of defeated me they came out okay
but they were sort of lopsided
and i had trouble with like the
waistband
so i just had to throw them out at the
end i think i got maybe like a c on him
or something
graham's asking me that if if we went if
we had trade school back in our days
what
what would what trade would we have
ended up
taking
i probably still would have taken
culinary
i probably still would have done that
or um
machinist i really would have liked that
i actually
did some of that for uh up in michigan
at broadhead armory it was it was a
machine gun shop did that for a while
before i joined the army
being a machinist
um
it's a possibility or being a
auto mechanic i like that also which i
do that too i can rebuild engines and
[ __ ] know all about internal combustion
uh so it'll been a mixture of those
three
which that's
that's uh
that's kind of part of the main mainstay
of [ __ ] and another thing that maybe i
would have been into is uh something
involved with construction you know
that'd have been interesting also
um i wouldn't mind doing something like
that actually mr action you're right i
mean if i would go to trade school and
they gave me like all the i would i
would like to get you'll learn how to
build build like a house
i think that would be really useful i
was thinking more like skyscrapers well
i mean that's it
pouring concrete uh
yeah that seemed like that seems like it
would be a release
building ships something like that i
probably would have enjoyed that
but military really
was the primary
thing you know coming up out of a
military academy i was always or
military oriented i was ready for that
so
when the war started i just [ __ ] went
right to where
my heart was i
you know military schools and
building models and tanks and
but i went straight to infantry airborne
infantry
and if i couldn't get that it would have
probably would have [ __ ] wanted to go
into an armory unit
but some of my friends or one friend of
mine trepaski
he went green to gold and became an
officer ended up being an armored
commander
and vanished into the [ __ ] officer
world and i linked up back up with him
on facebook years later
and he told me it was a good good thing
that i didn't go arbor he said he hated
it it was mostly just [ __ ]
maintaining and washing those damn
[ __ ] m1 abrams tanks
and it was more maintenance than doing
anything they rarely ever got to do
anything with them
so maybe it was a good thing
see that's why i was never real
interested in because i like doing
you know i complain about like i was
saying earlier about like an art
director making a lot more money than a
graphic designer even though the art
director is just kind of like the
manager of it and is not actually doing
the stuff but to be honest i don't think
that i would want to be the person
that's just like managing people and
telling other people what to do i'd
rather just do it myself because
actually i enjoy
the creative process and i do not think
i would enjoy just being in an office
telling other people to do this creative
thing even if i was making two times the
money which is probably why i never
really pursued even though i have enough
experience i never really pursued like a
managerial thing because that seems like
it would be really boring uh so i just
really really didn't never wanted to do
that smoochie says uh did you use your
easy bake oven i did i love that [ __ ]
and i actually had
because i know they had one
uh this was in the early 80s i think or
late 70s or early 80s when i had one i
know they had one that looked kind of
like more like a quote-unquote modern
kitchen or a contemporary one mine was
like an old school it was a holly hobby
branded
easy bake oven so it looked like an old
like little house on the prairie [ __ ]
like a cast iron oven yeah it looked
like an old yeah like one of those
really it was dark blue i think and it
had kind of like it was all like ornate
i love that [ __ ] thing and you just
like cooked stuff with a light bulb
so they give you like little packets of
stuff and some of the [ __ ] in there was
like not bad like the especially the
apple pie was actually pretty decent i
mean it was just like this big but it
was like a target the kid girls had it
yeah i had one yeah they liked it they
said it worked it did yeah i made uh
apple pies in it all the time i made
like little chocolate cakes
did you have to buy their little packets
or do they give you recipes on how to
make it um you could do either i usually
got the packets it came with i can't
remember how many packets it came with
but it came with a packet and then you
could like buy
uh you know extra packet sets okay or
they had like little recipes too so
they're like mixed together xyz and then
you know and then put it in there so you
could do it either way you can use your
own ingredients or theirs but i remember
some of the stuff being like pretty
decent i mean i was a little kid you
know so i'm sure i wasn't probably came
up like the little [ __ ] uh pies that
came out of the damn tv dinner it's
probably like that
you know what i actually think it was
better than that because because i
remember eating tv dinner so i know what
you're talking about i i ate tv dinners
a lot
they were better than that okay so i
will say that all right um
those are pretty good though out of a tv
dinner
that's what i'm saying so so it says
something that the ones from the easy
back up and at least the easy bake oven
i had like back in like the late 70s or
whatever
were actually pretty good i think there
were other ones too but the ones i the
the best ones i remember the apple pie
was the best one and then like the
chocolate cake was pretty good too and
it came with like the little frosting so
you could put frosting on it and um
i was going to say too that one of the
when i was talking about uh home mac and
shop and all that other kind of stuff
our shop was kind of fun like we did a
lot of woodworking and i made like some
[ __ ]
i made like a bunch of little planners
and pencil holders and [ __ ] like that
and um
[Music]
but i think my favorite of all those i
think was the graphics class that we had
because we did photography we built a
pinhole camera
and then we uh they taught us all of the
how to um develop a photograph like from
scratch well you even had to like take
the film
out of the pinhole camera like in one of
those little i don't even know if they
have these anymore
but one of those little bags that you
put your hands in it's black so you
don't expose the film to um to light
right so you stick your hands in there
and you take it out of the camera and
then you have to wind it around this
thing and put in this little cup and
then you have to take it and you expose
it and then like all the chemicals and
stuff so they we did that we did
drafting
uh you know you had to do like uh i
learned how to do blueprints all that
kind of [ __ ] so it's like but you know
pretty useful i don't use it in my job
or anything but
they're asking gary asked if we've seen
the new btk documentary oh i have not
wait how new are we talking about yeah
where is it how new and where is it what
do you talk about
because i see like a lot uh mr robotta
says do you and jenny have an ice cream
maker no we don't yeah no we don't i
haven't creamed that one yeah you don't
need one actually i had one when i was a
kid
um you know my dad had one so my dad and
my grandma always but they always made
peach ice cream with it because you
couldn't get peach ice cream
all year round at least back then
if you had then that was their favorite
if you have an immersion blender it's
like it's on a wand in the end like a
cuisinart type
and then you have um
uh something like the damn
what do you call it
uh protein powder
flavored protein powder like for you
know like muscle milk or uh [ __ ]
what's the other one body fortress
which is
vanilla or chocolate flavored protein
even have a banana flavor wait it's
called body fortress body fortress i got
that one that's a good one too
that's hilarious
what a hilarious name you could drop
that
down into a mixing cup
like three scoops of that
and just a half full maybe two
two handfuls of [ __ ] ice out of your
ice maker
and then use the immersion blender and
grind that [ __ ] together and it will
turn into instant [ __ ]
soft serve ice cream but instead of it
being ice cream it'll be a pro it'll be
a
whey protein based ice cream which is
all over europe eastern europe they love
ice cream just like that and it's like
soft serve ice cream you wouldn't know
that that was protein it's a lot better
for you
fewer calories
fewer carbohydrates same flavor and you
can flavor it with
i like the vanilla because the vanilla
can then be flavored with like frozen
fruit
mix and stuff you know to give any
flavor you want or if you want to add a
little bit of damp chocolate powder you
know cocoa powder or chocolate syrup you
can turn it into chocolate
you know
so you can make there's other ways to
make ice cream shaking it in a bag with
rock salt around it that's how i've done
it like that before that's the easiest
way to do it like i said it's going to
be soft serve it's not going to be like
but that is ice cream
there are other things that are like ice
cream taste just like that they're even
better for you
ice cream is [ __ ]
very high in sugar well that everybody
knows sugar eggs milk cream but i mean
if you're gonna do the cow it's a it's a
once in a you know once in a while
indulgence because honestly i kind of
feel like
the the low sugar or the low fat stuff
is like not even worth it i feel like if
you're gonna eat it then just eat it
like once a month or something like that
and just like
just treat yourself don't get like the
low calorie [ __ ] because it's not good
everyone just seems like a waste every
day i have a protein at least one
protein drink and it's done with an
immersion blender ice cubes fruit juice
and [ __ ] uh vanilla protein
and you just
weigh protein and using an immersion
blender and that you can turn it into a
shake it's [ __ ] beautiful beautiful
and you can control how thick you want
it or how icy you want it or
um you know just by how much ice and how
much protein you're going to put in it
and
it's good
it's
it's not cheap you know whey protein
powder is not cheap
but
two scoops one scoop of that whey
protein powder if you look at the the
protein content it's about like a
chicken breast
with like 60 70 80 calories that's not
much calories and it's a lot of good
flavor so
you know you can have a very high
protein low calorie
meal or snack
i mean if i'm going to do that i'd
rather not have a shake i'd rather just
eat like a couple hard-boiled eggs or
something
yeah it tastes a lot better
those eggs doesn't have that amount of
protein i know but like those protein
shakes kind of gross me out it's in your
mind it's i can make them taste just
like a
well yeah where else would it be it's in
your mind
i've i think they're great i can make
them just like uh you can use instead of
instead of uh fruit juice you can use
cold coffee
80 90 calories i'd rather have like just
a hard-boiled egg or something
right with like a shake this is like
four times the amount of protein i know
that yeah i know that i'm talking about
calories
uh
calories don't matter that much in that
context
because it's like a meal substitute
mandy says uh what i was talking about
earlier yeah i managed to tattoo and
piercing studios and man i want out of
management i just want to do my graphic
design stuff as well yeah see this is
why
i mean ever since i was got into graphic
design i was like that's
most of the time is fun not always
because sometimes you're doing like some
stupid [ __ ] and like people are really
picky or whatever
but
i would rather just do that i don't want
to like manage people that are doing
that
and then not get to do it and honestly i
heard the same thing from people that
were my managers like art directors and
places that i worked they were always
kind of like man i wish i could go back
and like do what you guys are doing
instead of just like be sitting here
like [ __ ] graham said he got turned
off by the btk uh [ __ ] show because
he uh was too jazzed about i gotta see
it then i gotta see it what's the name
of this what's name of the show where is
it
i don't think anybody said where it was
i mean yeah i want to see where it's
been a while btk confessions of a serial
killer yeah i gotta see it is it on is
it on netflix
well i don't know i guess netflix lost
50 billion dollars today
one quarter of its value
damn mary says baskin robbins they had
grape ice cream and bubble gum ice cream
yeah it was good i used to eat it as a
kid no black licorice ice cream it was
[ __ ] great for the 31 flavors and
also the uh the pumpkin [ __ ] ice
cream i loved that okay pumpkin ice
cream i could get behind that well they
had pumpkin and black licorice and that
was for [ __ ] halloween it was [ __ ]
great well see i don't want any [ __ ]
black licorice in there guys
pumpkin like pumpkins good though
no i just don't like the same flavors as
you i know that's very difficult for you
to get your
head around it
now jason asked do i still have what is
what's he what did he ask he says do i
still have fatigue and did i keep anyway
first of all i don't know what
decade this is in there's no such thing
as fatigues during the time that i was a
during the time i was when we had bdu
which is battle dress uniform there's no
reason to
keep any of that you know it was [ __ ]
90s it was looking marpat i got all
kinds of [ __ ] that's so much better than
mil-spec
and you know there's no reason to keep a
weapon you can't keep any military
weapons all things are signed in and out
out of arms rooms and highly controlled
stuff
i don't know what country you're living
in but
here in the u.s you can get things that
are far better
than uh military specifications small
arms
you know now the military can get a hold
of things like bell feds and they can
get old you can get that too here in the
u.s they have it just that it's more
lengthy licensing process
uh but just off-the-shelf stuff and
stuff that you can build
you can meet or exceed military
specifications
which
military specification i mean some guys
have really been out of shape about that
but they don't understand how the trials
go and politics and
the kind of abuse that a [ __ ]
a military-issued weapon goes through
you know it's an institutional [ __ ]
weapon which means it's being handed
from one [ __ ] bag to another who's
probably abusing it it's not exactly the
same situation as say like private
security or special operations or
civilian
it's going to be a totally different
scene you know it doesn't have to be
mil-spec you just have to understand
what it is you're dealing with and what
the mission is
so uh now you really don't want or need
anything that the military has
not when you're not if you're not if
you're in the u.s
and this goes back to what i said before
you had dudes saying oh well you know we
have all these nuclear weapons and all
these jets and all these tanks
none of those are war-winning weapons
that is the totally irrelevant
conventional weapons are used to engage
a conventional army to break down a
conventional army to get into their
country and take over their
basically their institutions and their
governments to get people to obey and it
tends to fail
conventional warfare going back
af world the last conventional war that
actually worked was world war ii
after that conventional war failed it
has a [ __ ]
piss-poor track record everything is
unconventional
what's working now is [ __ ] you'd see in
[ __ ] double 07.
[ __ ] james bond [ __ ] that's that
works
conventional wars [ __ ] just chumps
game
grandfather's hammer says the bug the
bubble gum in bubble gum ice cream was
like chewing on cold rocks amazing i
never lost a tooth i loved it yeah i
love it i mean there were different
kinds because i think there were some
that had like chunks of bubble gum in it
and then there were some that were just
like bubble gum flavored both of them
are [ __ ] i don't like that i don't
like
well like i said i'm not a big fan of
fruity ice creams or any of those kind
of like stunt flavors
you know i'm kind of more like a coffee
nut mint type of person
so
not a big fan of that butter pecan is
good also
yeah um yeah so i do kind of want to
watch that btk thing but i know where
you're coming from because i've seen
some interviews with him and i read that
book
uh that what did i the book was also
called confessions of a serial killer so
maybe actually the documentary is based
on the book um
and he really sounds like i mean
obviously he's a serial killer but he
also just on top of that just sounds
like a giant [ __ ] douchebag
um
you know and he definitely is getting
off on recounting
he i mean he's really into like how
famous he is
i feel like because he likes to recount
the crimes because he gets off on it
which is [ __ ] up you know
graham's talking about everything he
carried when he was a cop
spinning western 66 the three to seven
yeah the 66 was good i had a uh
what was the uh
the 586 and the 686 which is this which
is the stainless steel version i had
them both in uh
four inch barrels and six inch and 357
magnum i used to hand load them 357.
[ __ ]
use those hogue finger [ __ ] group
grips and [ __ ] form uh adjustable sights
there it was a fun revolver revolvers
often
discounted nowadays uh
but when you talk about [ __ ] accuracy
out of a pistol it [ __ ] longer ranges
[ __ ] revolver was the way to go man
that was pretty good also you said um
smith wesson 40 uh 4046 uh the 4046 that
was a stainless steel automatic it's
their semi-automatic pistol or the 46 i
believe
that was a
it was the 40 version of the [ __ ]
nine if i remember correctly i remember
those jason says i live in england guess
they call them different things now oh
okay yeah uh
he's talking about fatigue yeah
potentially his old [ __ ] term 50s
1950s and then gary says uh i'm in
ireland and then he says thought
everyone here was american
not everybody there are actually all
over the world there are a lot of brits
here uh we have a couple sandra i don't
think she's here tonight she's american
she's uh german yeah and we have uh
sometimes we have a guy from saudi
arabia sometimes we have a couple that's
not here today yeah we have a couple of
uh people from mexico
you know there's like lots of different
people and uh north mexico also known as
southern california
we have some of those
but uh no uh and then he's going yeah
also man the sig 228 that was a [ __ ]
great pistol great steel frame pistol
glock 26 i remember that one yeah that
was a good one too
870 yeah that was a [ __ ] standby
cruiser
uh mini 14 i've had i had the mini 30
too that was a good one also the m4 the
sbr version yeah it's a 14 inch barrel
that's good yeah i should bring some
uppers in here man i i can't bring an
assembled weapon in here on a live
stream the ai will [ __ ] immediately
ding you
because people have brought [ __ ]
stuff in
to live streams and shot themselves
alive on a live stream so i'm real
afraid to bring anything in
during the live stream because there's
ai watching and i don't know
how it
the i don't know how the ai recognizes
stuff
i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna bring
anything in here because we'd probably
lose the stream
it's okay if it's something recorded but
live stream it it might be a problem
but i got a [ __ ] xm177 [ __ ] uh
clone
uh i've got [ __ ] some facts and
barreled ultralight ar-15 uppers without
[ __ ] with with uh without forward
bolt assist no [ __ ] uh
not even dust cover like an ultralight
[ __ ] builds i got some of those i got
um 16 inch [ __ ] heavy barrel with
[ __ ] full rails that go all the way
out to the end
uh [ __ ] ton of different kinds of mags
a bunch of different kind of [ __ ]
butt stocks you know [ __ ] mil-specs
stuff
um
uh [ __ ]
uh
more what's the name of that [ __ ]
company [ __ ]
uh mad polk a lot of magpul furniture
a lot of [ __ ] vintage furniture uh
one of my uppers is a 16 inch
uh [ __ ] heavy barreled version of a
dissipator with the a2 barrel and a1
style triangular [ __ ] hand guards
that's a pretty good one uh ak builds uh
[ __ ]
i've got some smith
pistols
i've got um
i'm a [ __ ] big fan of [ __ ] walther
stuff i've got some [ __ ] walther p99s
and ppq type stuff
uh
nine to forty conversions uh i got stuff
that's let's say suppressor adjacent
suppressor ready
type stuff with that um
i have uh some custom stuff working
that's all i'm gonna talk about right
now
that's all on top one of the things that
i wanted to do is i wanted to do a
custom mac 10 type build but something
that looks kind of south african
integrally suppressed but i have to
worry about the licensing with that
how would i go through the licensing to
do integrally suppressed full body
[ __ ] mac 10
but
south africans were working on something
like that back in the 80s
side folders
let me go to the rescue model
yeah i was just about to go but yeah
when i come back
uh john gore says hey i freak out over
blazes too i don't uh i don't know
actually
i never really like worried that much
about it
because that's not really something i
would do on the show so i don't really
know
i've never honestly um
we have never run into problems i don't
think that
literally the only strikes i've ever
gotten were like copyright strikes you
know i think one time
tom was
showing like a video of some band that
he was talking about and i got a
copyright strike for that they didn't
take the video down but they gave me a
copyright strike and i think
back in the old days when i used to put
kind of like snippets of songs at the
end that had to do with whatever the
topic was i got a couple copyright
strikes on those but that's
i don't think i've ever gotten like [ __ ]
because i know like tom likes to be
really paranoid but we can't talk about
this we can't talk about that but i've
literally like never gotten sometimes
the um the monetization is limited like
if you talk about serial killers or like
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that um
but it doesn't happen all that much so i
haven't really run into that many
problems
you know
maybe other channels have problems but i
have not really had any
um
you know as i said they do uh limited
ads on
[ __ ] that's like
gruesome like serial killers usually so
usually if i do something about true
crime then they'll still show ads but
you know a lot of um you know
advertisers don't want to be on that so
it's like a smaller pool but that's
pretty much the only thing that i've
noticed
uh you know
gary says
uh can we take a minute to appreciate
that jen always has cool hair
[Laughter]
thank you
i actually my hair i just i don't know
what to do with it well because
this i had this part shaved like
underneath
and i didn't actually mean to grow it
back out but i just got too lazy to
shave it
and now it's like too long to shave it
without it being this big [ __ ]
deal
so now i'm just kind of like well [ __ ] i
guess i'm growing it back out then and
so i don't really like know what to do
with it in the meantime and then
sometimes when we're doing the live
stream i'm just kind of like well i
don't really feel like wearing a wig
either because it's hot and so
you know it's just a whole thing it's a
whole thing i think about it a lot let's
see if the algorithm will pick that up
i thought you said you weren't gonna
like uh do you just wanna see well i'm
going to the bathroom okay good
i don't think the alcohol you were there
it's xm177 styled upper
all right
here's another one
hollywood dissipator
remember that
north hollywood style
it didn't seem to
pick it up
yeah there it is
okay
all right
so i seem to have gotten away with it
okay
tammy's if i can take pictures of him
i kind of tend to kind of keep that [ __ ]
kind of low
but i did show you the uppers
okay they're asking me about beretta who
goes after which bread are you talking
about who goes beretta made a lot of
stuff
you might be talking about what a
beretta
92f probably that's like the most famous
ones the 92f that was like what you saw
in um
um die hard is that what you're talking
about
gary says you should have worn the wig
doing that though yeah yeah i've been
looking cooler yeah
everybody's talking about what they have
and all their guns and [ __ ]
i mean i was saying while you were gone
that
honestly i haven't really had any
problems with anything yeah
only time i ever got strikes was for a
music copyright right like if we played
some [ __ ] from a band or something well
i don't think or like i said the the ads
are limited if you do something
like about like something graphic or
gruesome like about serial killers or
something but
they don't take the ads off there's just
not as many
yeah options that's all cam guys says
classic uh james bond classic books have
been using a walther ppk i don't know
what that means size what i said but i
do know it's a semi-auto okay the ppk
that they were that they were talking
about in the original books
it's about that big
and it was a
straight blowback
semi-automatic pistol
it was uh dual it was a double action
single action which means that
the first pull was a long pull like a
revolver that would [ __ ] the hammer and
fire off the first round and then the
slide would come back and [ __ ] the
hammer after every round after that it
became single action but the original
actually was 765 millimeter also known
as 32 acp that's what bond originally
carried
it was a nice little pistol in its day
it has a very heavy trigger pull by
today's standards uh kind of heavy
and um
would have been expensive they still
sell them because of bond
uh later on they upgraded it to 380
which is kind of like a weaker version
of nine millimeter it was a good little
caliber of a lot of 380s that's that's
probably about the bare minimum you'd
ever want to carry
um but what was kind of ridiculous is in
the james bond excuse me in the daniel
craig james bond movies
he started off
in casino royale with a walther p99 i
have one of those it's a [ __ ]
beautiful
service pistol
um the size
the size is perfect got a really nice
trigger pull
uh it's got a really nice trigger
package in it
um it starts off with that but then by
the second movie they got him back with
the ppk well the ppk is very out of date
by today's standards that's a that's an
antique
so it didn't really quite make sense and
he's fighting against dudes with [ __ ]
full full auto sub machine guns and
full-sized pistols and it's just
the ppk was a pocket pistol
and you don't want that
not today
that's something you carry around with
you just don't have many much clothes on
and you just put something in your
pocket you know
and you you they got even smaller and
lighter than that today for a fraction
of the cost
so um
the ppk thing is a james bond thing and
it's just it's not realistic anymore
it's it's it's out of date they're nice
though my dad has one
danny rolling ghostface says just saw
the film army of the dead not bad at all
zombie flick just saying and then cheryl
says didn't love that movie yeah i heard
very mixed uh
reactions to it
i kind of feel like when it first came
out like a lot of people were like oh
awesome but then like after a while
people like oh wait not awesome so
i was actually gonna watch it and then i
just never got around to it and then i
forgot about it so there's that whole
thing i mean eventually i'll probably
get around to it but god damn it i got
like so many [ __ ] things i gotta
watch i did actually start because i
know a couple of you recommended
archive 81 and i did actually start
watching that so i did i watched the
first two episodes and it's like awesome
so far so yeah i'm gonna like finish
that out i still gotta finish midnight
mass too goddammit i watched like the
first three or four of that and then
like
i never got around to finish in the end
i just uh i don't know i have a dd or
something i don't know what it is cheryl
says i'm canadian i have no idea what
tom's talking about well you have no
idea about canadian laws
canadians have some cooler [ __ ] than we
have
they just can't own pistols and i think
they have a limitation on i think i
think they might have a limit a magazine
limitation
but in in canada you can have short
braille rifles you can have all kinds of
stuff that you that would require a
license here in the u.s so uh
canada isn't as different as you think
it is um the whole pistol thing that's
that's kind of sideways i don't really
understand that
but okay
john gore says i just saw hereditary
that was awesome thank you
that's actually probably my favorite
horror movie of the last five or ten
years i [ __ ] love hereditary i've
seen it two times we saw in the theater
and then we bought it and like i watched
it again and i still [ __ ] love it
it's so [ __ ] good and honestly the
more times you watch it the better it
gets
um because you pick up so much more [ __ ]
there's all kind of [ __ ] going on in the
background of that stuff like all kind
of like symbolism and all kind of like
[ __ ] you didn't notice first time around
and it's just
i love that i love when so much like
detail is put into it oh another movie
i'm gonna i did a review of this like i
recorded a review of it but it won't be
up until next week
but i don't know if you some of you guys
have seen it it came out in 2018 and
it's called in fabric it's the same guy
what the [ __ ] his name peter
strickland same guy that directed
barbarian sound studio which was like a
giallo throwback which i also loved and
i reviewed that as well and i've been
wanting to see in fabric for a really
long time and i saw it the other day
it's gonna be it's super divisive i get
that like some people are watching it
being like what the [ __ ] did i just
watch i [ __ ] loved it i thought it
was [ __ ] amazing but
your mileage may vary
it's very surreal and it's kind of a
black comedy but it's like a weird
very very dry british humor but i like
that and it like looks gorgeous it looks
like a giallo movie but it's not exactly
but i like like his throwback i like
that dude's style man cause like i said
i really liked barbarian sound studio as
well
have you seen last night in soho we did
great movie uh i yeah i loved it i
thought it was awesome yeah it was a
good movie of that year we saw that in
the theater yeah like not just a couple
months ago yeah yeah whenever it came
out
uh cool one two two one nine four says
just watched zardoz that [ __ ] was epic
yes thanks for breaking it up
dr zardoz is far more epic than i
remembered it i didn't quite understand
zardos on the first viewing
um but you know with all the [ __ ] that's
been coming up lately you know what i
mean
uh about [ __ ]
depopulation programs and uh how the
rich people are trying to get rid of
everybody so they can inherit the earth
and
uh divide and conquer strategies and
getting warriors to [ __ ] enslave and
murder [ __ ] the peasants it was
[ __ ] a great movie man real good and
uh
yeah i want that [ __ ] on blu-ray
waiting for one of y'all to send it to
me
i'm trying to get a free movie but no
shameless time i know uh but same
director who did excalibur if you
haven't seen excalibur yeah john borman
you've got to see excalibur one of my
favorite movies that [ __ ] would bring
[ __ ] a lump to your throat it'll just
bring out the inner honky the vanilla
gorilla [ __ ] rises up to his [ __ ]
celtic slash anglo saxon roots when he
sees [ __ ]
arthur
and then you hear wagner in the back
hell yeah hell yeah although an
excalibur i'm super into like merlin in
that one yeah merlin's good in it i love
everybody's good what's his name nickel
something
[ __ ] a camera yeah
if you have a genesis in the [ __ ]
british islands
you know
it's
they've done the [ __ ] genetic tests
that i [ __ ] heard about you know the
averages what you're talking about is
saxon men and celtic women because those
were the winners of the time because
those saxons came in there and they [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and they got all the damn
celtic women [ __ ] pregnant but it's
it's male s
saxon male lines and
celtic female lines that's that's
what we kind of are mostly
gary that's the world that's being shown
in a certain way in in that movie of
excalibur it's kind of and
ugrain
she looked
it wasn't yeah the grain looked very
celtic
and everybody else kind of looked kind
of germanic
it's a good movie great movie great
movie and it was ancient zardoz very
very similar theme
gary says have you guys watched mind
hunter yes
uh and they were [ __ ] awesome
i really do hope they do another season
of that that would be rad yeah charlotte
rampling was in sardos yes she was
um and helen marin was in
uh excalibur
rare although you know charlotte
rampling is like [ __ ] hot too just
gonna say
what was that movie she was in uh [ __ ]
night god damn it
somebody will help me somebody will
somebody will know what i'm talking
about
jason says with kovid being a global
killer these last few years do you see
many films and books written about in
the future already have been
uh
man chuck tingle was right on that [ __ ]
i think he's already got some like uh
covet era erotica
i mean well i have to look at his
wikipedia page i do check it every now
and then because his titles
the titles of his books just make my
[ __ ] day just like reading through
the list i'm just kind of like okay
all's right with the world now chuck
tingle is still out there
writing his weird ass erotica
coming up with these [ __ ] crazy and
he's very very topical i love it i love
it people asking questions about
revolvers i'm getting them kind of
confused about the charlotte charter
arms 38
that who was it that used that that was
the
dude the dude that killed john lennon
the charter arms was a [ __ ] real
cheap revolver
an american media thank you yeah the
real cheap american-made revolver it was
just kind of ungainly and ugly it was
they weren't bad they just were uh
real low budget they weren't as nice as
a smith and wesson
um the the best one was the 44 bulldog
um it was a harder hitting cartridge and
that was the one son of sam used to use
the 44 bulldog you get one of those like
less than 100 bucks back in those days
and then somebody mentioned uh 44 magnum
and his uh you know how much that shoots
or whatever i don't really know what the
question is
smith and wesson 44 magnum was a large
frame revolver very well made uh it came
in many different barrel lengths
44 uh magnum was a very powerful round
based on 44 special in 44 russian uh it
was expressly made for um smokeless
powder which is a lot more concentrated
so they lengthened them
so they could not go into 44 special
revolvers um
those were not really combat revolvers
they were hunting revolvers you don't
need that much power for
anti-personnel purposes
that's something you use for deer or it
was more of a hunting type revolver
although some dudes would try to man up
and [ __ ] you know dirty harry and
everything and he's they're showing him
using it like a police pistol
kind of unrealistic i mean you know the
rate of fire is pretty slow it's a lot
of recoil you don't need that much power
it's
it's more power than you actually need
but they were nice they're real
well made revolvers out of style though
now all that stuff's kind of gone by the
way side [ __ ] revolvers are expensive
and complicated to make they're
mechanical repeaters
any kind of automatic pistol is far
easier and cheaper to make
there's far
fewer moving parts and just uh
you know
you can make them a lot faster
holy [ __ ] damn thank you very much who
is this john robertson john roberts hey
guys i'm watching the book of boba fett
and i feel like i'm watching the sci-fi
version of tom's origin story
time you'd love it i've been hearing bad
things about it is it good
yeah i haven't really because i i want
to watch it so i've been trying to like
avoid what do you say anything uh jenny
i'm gonna purchase your book soon thank
you my 21st birthday is coming up holy
crap you're a baby uh i'm going to
purchase my first handgun thank you so
much that's so nice of you i mean what
state you in goodness gracious what
state you in
i wanted to mention up here too that
granthar's hammer said that he had been
meaning to send us
spring breakers and charlie wilson's war
i promise one day charlie wilson's war
is actually really good i saw that in
the theater that's one of tom hanks
right yeah yeah yeah uh yeah i saw that
in theater i used to see a lot of movies
back in the theater back in the day let
me lay some [ __ ] out to you john
so you're gonna buy your first handgun
[ __ ] handguns are um
they're dif
a lot i don't know how much shooting
experience you have they're
hard to use
correctly in combat they require more
training
um they're weaker
than a rifle if you go to a gunfight
with a pistol you're a [ __ ] dumbass
that's the last thing you want to take
you want to take a
rifle what a pistol is about is
concealment and portability if you're a
law enforcement agent you can carry one
on your hip and not you're not as
intimidating walking around with a rifle
even though they have something like
that in the patrol vehicle usually
and you know they can go about their
daily routine of enforcing law
you can have a pistol there
um you pistols are good for concealment
but when it comes to self-defense home
defense you want rifle
and usually for less than the cost of a
good pistol you can get an ar-15 which
is oh no that's where you want to go
that's where you want to be
so
be careful what you wish for i do not
recommend pistols as the first
firearm
it's always a backup that's like a
dagger it's close range it's emergency
only they require
more skills to use properly and they're
not a primary weapon it's a secondary
one primary weapon's always rifle it's
so much so much more
ability you can reach out to 300 meters
500 meters
more ammunition capacity
more reliability
more speed more ease of use it's just so
much better to get a rifle but dji
maniac says and i have yet to send you
nothing but trouble for a review yet
i'll need the new address yeah well uh
instant message me and i'll send you the
new address nothing but trouble i
haven't seen it since probably the early
1990s and i remember it being batshit
insane and even back then thinking how
much coke were they doing when they made
this movie but i haven't really seen it
in a long time so because i remember it
just being like what the
like okay
uh oh thank you again john uh i'm from
arkansas and it really is an awesome
show thank you very much
that is really really awesome out in
arkansas then you got plenty of plenty
of room out there to practice with a
rifle i'd get a rifle if you don't have
one yeah
pistol's never the first choice get an
ar-15 or an ak art right now
ar-15 is the buyer's market go with the
psa palmetto state armory
you can get something real nice for
under 400
everybody's probably everybody saying
yourself everybody's saying that you
should probably put on the mullet wig
like as a sort of like weird homage to
meatloaf even though he didn't well he
kind of had a mullet right
i mean you know
well
it's weird because we only just reviewed
the rocky horror picture show
like a month or two ago
even though i'd seen it a million times
since i was a kid but
uh you know
what happened to them
i don't know you're the one that tosses
the [ __ ] in there and doesn't put it
back the way i bought all these nice
little wig stands
how long did that last not very long he
just like chucked stuff in the closet
[Laughter]
well i don't know what you did with it i
didn't move it i see the uh
you can just dig through all the other
wigs i don't know what you did with it
it's either right there on that side or
it's up on the top
yeah i was like i don't all the wigs are
in there okay
i mean mine are hanging up because i
have like the hanging wig stands for the
longer wigs but the shorter ones are
just over there on the little ones
you need to get you on a wig why aren't
you tart it up tonight
you need to get your ass tarted up i
want [ __ ] boobs and everything boobs
and wigs and oh shut up well because the
yeah and you're the one that whines like
every time you have to wear a wig and
then like 10 minutes later it's like
this is hot
but he expects me to like wear the whole
thing the whole night so [ __ ] that
it's friday night i actually you know
we're hanging out at home okay
i want to be comfortable let me go the
restroom hold on you know yeah
they're hot
you know that and you don't even have
hair underneath the wig i do
so i have to put like a wig cap on and
it's a whole thing so
you know
like i said it's easy when you don't
have to do it um
yeah he kind of he did have a mullet in
rocky or kinda
uh
he's a pre-military he was a man before
his time
honestly i don't know did you guys see
okay so he was on
uh i mean he was in a lot of movies
obviously he was in fight club he was
man tits and um
he was also in
remember when they did was it hbo i
think that where they did masters of
horror and it was like two seasons and
they had all of these big horror
directors at john carpenter and dario
argento and all these people and they
made like hour-long movies
and i think you can watch most of on
hulu or maybe they're on 2b i'm not
actually sure but meatloaf was in one
called pelts
and he was like he played a fur trader
and what was he doing it was something
about like he was uh catching like
raccoons and making like raccoon codes
or whatever and then like he ends up
getting skinned
you know it was actually a pretty good
one he's actually a good actor i don't
know why i mean i guess he was in a lot
of stuff but
uh he was in spice world yeah yeah
i mean you can't win them all
i haven't seen spice world i don't know
i've seen like clips from it but
i don't know it's one of those movies
where i kind of feel like from a
cultural standpoint i should probably
watch it but then i'm just kind of like
god there's so many good movies that i
have to watch like before i get to that
maybe when i'm like 90. i'll get around
to it
yeah tammy says friday's our casual
night just hang with our friends no
reason to get tarted up i did think
about it earlier but then i was just
kind of like man no i don't feel like it
i don't feel like it
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] mullet is
ridiculous
it suits you
because you because you are i went to
the bathroom with this on
well what are you going to do take it
off and then yeah
yeah yeah it's like i got to put a vest
on to take a piss and then if i could
why don't you get this
i can't i keep telling him why does he
have targeted up what are you talking
about she's just [ __ ] hounds
automatically why don't you put on it
sounds automatically when you look like
me you just why don't you put on some
makeup and a corset and some high heeled
shoes and oh now she's trying to that's
like something that's like something
[ __ ] would wear i'm looking like i'm
looking in that i look at the damn i
look at the screen you look like okay
rodney ryder piper you look like joe
dirt
or
ratty water roddy piper that works
now you need the glasses what glasses
from they live from now oh yeah they
live yeah yeah i don't have
oh my god that's again that's your next
year's halloween costume yeah it would
work yeah
that would have oh
i don't know why that never occurred to
me before that would be a great [ __ ]
halloween costume for you to do and i'm
all out
yeah and you'd have to go around say
well i mean you'd have to say it like
every time somebody came up to you
yeah i've come here to chew bubble gum
and kick ass
you could just wear a shirt that said
that i guess and then you wouldn't like
mike and a guitar now
yeah
oh my god
uh
yeah it's just you know
[Laughter]
tom piper lol yeah i don't know why i
never thought of that before
but yeah you could totally do that they
live thing
you could you could be rowdy riding
piper and i could be one of the aliens i
could be like one of the creepy like i
could have on like the 80s power suit
and then have like the because i think
they make masks of that do they not
they're making fun of me for eating
licorice licorice black licorice ice
cream
they're not making funny thomas here to
eat licorice ice cream and wear wigs
and he's all out of licorice ice cream
so
he's just gonna wear a wig
i didn't even murder horn is sending me
all kinds of videos of him [ __ ] with
people down at the mexican border he
sends me all kinds of [ __ ] videos of
him [ __ ] with these bums that he that
he meets when he's going through the
mexican border and uh what's that dude's
name murder horde there's this little
one that keeps [ __ ] yelling at him
you lied to me you lied to me because
he goes i didn't promise you anybody
he's like you know you promised me
twenty dollars
[ __ ] it
that's [ __ ] up when you're moving from
one country to the next and they got an
old [ __ ] bomb waiting for you
you owe me money
on your way into the other country well
you lied to me you know he did some [ __ ]
it's a good uh i didn't tell you i was
gonna give you he sent me a whole video
of it him walking
into mexico and you hear this little
[ __ ] mexican dude going you know you
lied
[Music]
she was hilarious jason says were you
guys meatloaf fans um not as such i mean
like i said i you know i uh
you know i got how like talented he was
i liked him a rocky horror picture like
i said i liked his acting he was great
in fight club he was great in like
masters of horror and he had like an
incredible [ __ ] voice and honestly
when
i kind of feel like when uh like bad out
of hell came out or yeah that's what it
was right
i think it was that big album with uh
steinman
whatever it was
yeah yeah yeah and i kind of feel like
nobody else was really doing that
because it was almost kind of like
rock and roll but like show tunes at the
same time
and
i mean he was kind of like one of the
only dudes that could really like pull
that off
you know so gabe that's his name gabriel
that's the name of the damn mexican bump
gabriel
gabriel's yelling
that's [ __ ] funny i need to show a
video of [ __ ] gabriel [ __ ] hunting
you down trying to get 20 out of you
hornet that'd be funny as [ __ ]
sorry i just thought of that john cusack
movie yeah
two dollars yeah with that kid on the
bike like chasing him for the newspapers
that was better off dead right yeah
there's another 80s movie i feel like a
lot of people don't talk about better
off dad even though that was like
for real like one of the better 80s teen
movies gonna say
you show up in another country and they
gotta do waiting for you you owe me
money
you lied to me
you said you were gonna give me twenty
dollars
that's just [ __ ] funny
yeah dj maniac said uh
jim simon wrote for sisters of mercy too
yeah i thought he did hashtag and now
you know yeah does jenny have a wig i
have lots of wigs she's got all kinds of
wigs i do
i just i usually wear i got all kinds of
outfits man she just she dress up i got
we got pictures over at the [ __ ] club
i don't know if i've shown them on there
you know she looked like a damn [ __ ]
porn sorry
i'll [ __ ] show you some pictures
i'll show you all some pictures
uh oh he's showing yeah he's showing
pictures of me
he doesn't usually do that
grandpa's hammer said true story
meatloaf they know what you think that's
right well yeah they know what you look
like i look better when i dress up but
but like i said it's a lot of times i
just don't feel like it
[Laughter]
because it's a lot of it's a lot of work
it takes like two or three hours you
know
and jenny when she's dressed up at the
club that was a mannequin
there's the hookah pipe yeah
okay let's see if i get some more
okay this is a good one
don't even forget but gary said when
will we have a how tom and jet tom and
jen met live stream oh that was my bride
of frankenstein outfit
me dancing drunk drunk off my ass look
at me and i'm just kind of like yeah
like a mule eating briars
[Laughter]
okay that was a good outfit that came
out good i thought
jenny dancing like the bride of
frankenstein's my bride if i could stand
again and that's all my real hair i
didn't even have a wig for that [ __ ]
can't really see that one too well
uh
yeah grantham said i saw meatloaf three
times in concert once in portland oregon
twice in detroit always a fun show rock
and roll opera yeah i mean
he was kind of like
the [ __ ] master at that there's jen
with her blue wig on oh yeah that's my
blue wig i do like that one yeah it is
very hot
and it's very long so it's always kind
of like getting tangled and everything
because i wear like a lot of rings and
bracelets so it's like you go like that
and then like the hair like wraps up in
it yeah it's that same night that was
before we went anywhere no we were in
the we were at chantals
oh that's right we're in shantous and
i'm [ __ ] sitting there i'm trying to
get some right there i'm in the
restaurant and i was just kind of
chantal's [ __ ] yeah it's like we're
gonna eat can you please take my course
that i was trying to hit eat some food i
was trying to hit right there in the
[ __ ] restaurant
and then this guy he's spent they were
doing like karaoke yeah
they used to do karaoke that was only a
few months back
look at jen's boob [ __ ] [ __ ] pump
poking in that [ __ ] right there that's
hittable as [ __ ] i didn't talk about it
anymore he's not gonna talk i'm not
gonna talk about it anymore
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah there's a still from that
night
that's i was still putting makeup on
yeah i have my horns yeah
i like mine i'm sitting there
taking pictures of her [ __ ] booty and
[ __ ] i was like dude i'm trying to
finish my hair yeah yeah yeah i know
[Laughter]
he's so invasive i do what i'm doing
no sorry why are you kicking me
that's what she looks like
everybody knows that that's what she
looked like when she dressed up i'm
sitting there i'm trying molasses [ __ ]
i'm trying to when i go out i don't have
to wear glasses i only wear glasses when
i do the show because i can't see
everyone's comments otherwise i don't
normally wear glasses these are just
reading glasses
so you know
[Laughter]
all right let's see this is the other
[ __ ] from the night
that's what god girls look like that's
our friend aurora and jenny's up there
trying to get in
look at that big clunky yeah
we're trying to get into mannequins
that's down sanford
okay
oh i got one of me and um
okay
me and toby oh there's toby i've been
talking about toby all the time that's
my [ __ ] best buddy right there that's
also mannequin it's also mannequins
you guys are we are [ __ ] loaded y'all
were really drunk yeah
[Laughter]
it was super fun that's the leather
daddy i'm telling you about some of my
best friends [ __ ] leather daddy
[ __ ] that's that's the local
rob halford
i have sometimes i got videos of [ __ ]
him molesting jenny
did you get videos of that because he's
very handy when he's yeah he gets very
handsy he likes girls when he's drunk
all right this is he forgets he's gay
yeah he forgets he's gay there's jenny
and everybody else
this is out in the back
that's on the patio patio
there's andy yeah
the grandpa see the girl in a wig that's
jenny jeffrey's little sister that we
went to school with gary yeah yeah
can't really see it
see if i get some other
murder hornet return says i want to go
to a goth bar never been oh they're
super fun
super fun
what's that one
that's toby dean there's toby again yeah
yeah toby's rad
he's older than you are about a couple
years
yeah he's he wants me to train 50s mid
50s yeah he wants me to train him
he wants to get big
he can get big easy
jason says tom is a friendly drunk oh
yeah most of the time yeah
most of the time yeah
[Music]
the crap there's hammer said well jenny
some dope moves
was that i was probably like really
because honestly
i don't know like as i've gotten older i
kind of gotten a lot more
i went through a period where i wasn't
as self-conscious and it's like i would
just kind of go out on the dance floor
and dance by myself and i'd give a [ __ ]
but now i kind of like well i need to be
like kind of half liquored up before i
even go out there because i feel like
everyone's like looking at me jason's
like i'm single i need a goth girl then
go ahead and pass it up because the best
way to get a goth girl is if you already
have a girlfriend
[Laughter]
if you're single they don't want you
well i kind of feel like that's not just
gods that's like across the board well
because they kind of feel like well if
you don't already have or if you didn't
already have like some girlfriends at
some point it's like everybody's just
kind of like well why not
and i'm not saying that that's always
legit i'm just saying that that's kind
of like what people will think of
there's this uh hi there's this
weird uh
misconception that girls are easy no
goth girls come set on expert yeah i
think they're set on actually i think
most of them are like harder together
you might as well try to get a uh what's
easier would be like a damn
yuppy girl or a preppy girl [ __ ] or
you know a lot easier
goth girls well people have a
misconception
because a lot of god's chicks will work
kind of like fetishy looking stuff yeah
you think that's a slug and it becomes a
fetish yeah for people that don't see
that all the time so i do kind of feel
like there's a thing where dudes are
like oh well she must be a [ __ ] so i can
like get that really easily she might be
a [ __ ] but she's not your [ __ ] right
okay yeah she yeah she she's looking for
a goth dude
and you gotta have a long history of it
you have to have an identity in that
scene
you know i mean it's like rock stars
you know what i mean
it's like rock stars dating each other
if you're not a rock star you can't get
eight it's like yeah so that's the thing
it's as [ __ ] as some goth goth chicks
look if you come in there rolling up
thinking yeah because i like and we've
said this before like a lot of god's
chicks get kind of these preppy dudes
coming up in their like izzod shirts or
whatever the [ __ ] they're wearing
nowadays with the collars and like
coming up in their cargo shorts and
you know and they're in those big ass
[ __ ]
white clunky tennis shoes yeah that they
wear with those shorts and the shirt's
tucked in i don't get that but okay and
then they come in and they just think
they're going to be like hey hey lady
what's wrong what's going on proper
black can i buy you a drink and then
most of them are going to be like no
hardest
artists tell me to get
to get uh toby on test to get him bulked
up is exactly he wants to go on he wants
to uh he he's a he's a nurse he's in the
medical industry
uh just he's his [ __ ] hours right now
are [ __ ] kicking his ass he said once
his once this [ __ ] blows over he'll
probably have the freedom to
start going on test and uh i i put him
in a right i i i'm gonna hook him up
with a decent clinic
um
because he's got to go through his blood
tests he's got to get his hcg [ __ ]
worked out and
and um
i want to train him i got my own gym
here
he would that that [ __ ] he's so lean
already
yeah that he would just like zero body
fat yeah
right you would be instant result with
him and he's a little bit older than me
so
he knows it's about time he should have
been on really he should have been on 10
years ago
but he's holed up real well for a guy
his age you know he looked good for a
guy's age
and that'd be cool that'd be cool if he
could like hang over here i mean i know
you'd mostly be doing y'all [ __ ] but
yeah
yeah he wants to he wants me to start
having some people over hang out it's
the time
and i have a tendency to want to charge
somebody you know what i mean [ __ ]
because really by tradition you should
pay somebody at least something for the
training i mean because it costs well
yeah i mean it's not free it's like your
time it's just kind of like well it's
the same thing that happens like you
know because i do graphic design and i
do it for a lot of people that work the
clubs and stuff and i don't charge them
as much as i would
a normal client quote-unquote that
doesn't know me yeah but
i don't know i do kind of feel like
there is still a kind of a thing where
people kind of want stuff for free or
for really cheap for y'all who don't
know you know um i i uh do teletraining
with uh hornet
yeah i've worked with hornet for well
[ __ ] how long has it been probably six
months now and he's [ __ ] coming along
great
okay
he's on hrt goes to mexico
and it's over the counter there and
looking um man he's come along good
got about another six months and he'll
be [ __ ] on top of his game uh but
so if you guys ever need any uh [ __ ]
online training we can do it online just
contact me and um
you know as long as we can work out some
kind of arrangement i can point at
anybody in the right direction male or
female
good with females too can train them got
got several of them that interesting one
interested in want to try and one of
them be laura laura wants to work out i
would actually love it if laura could
come over and hang out yeah she wants to
meet her in ages last time i saw her
yeah me and her and jen hung out in
downtown sanford and that was probably
like what six months ago laura man i
miss those girls yeah laura's uh her
problem is always finding the time
she's got kind of everyone's really busy
and the thing about it is that
we didn't help matters by moving farther
away from everybody like i like this
house i'm not like mad about it but i'm
just saying that's only 12 miles further
though yeah but you know i mean even
before people were kind of like oh
you're in sanford and now we're like 12
miles farther away than that
so some people are like no
well a lot of a lot of people do not
want to work in a public gym
and because i have a private gym here
it's
you know i don't blame him i never
worry about having somebody watching see
this yeah see this is why i was like i'm
going to get my own and honestly as long
as i've had at my old house like before
i met you i had like one of those
multi-gym things i had a [ __ ] uh you
know exercise bike i've always had [ __ ]
in my own house because it's like i'm
not one
public gyms are gross um because you
don't know like if somebody's ass
sweated all over that [ __ ] and they
didn't like clean it or whatever
and
i don't like being like [ __ ] looked
at i don't like being looked at
when i'm just doing [ __ ] like that
especially when i'm all sweaty and
disgusting i don't want to be [ __ ]
looking at me so yeah hornet he said he
bulked up and slimmed down how much he
uh uh hornet had re he recomped a lot of
recomposition he lost a lot of fat
it looks a lot better
um and i'm telling you i'm telling you
hornet
[ __ ] you're only halfway through it
next year you're gonna see you're gonna
[ __ ] look twice as good
you know
when you get to our age man the hormones
aren't there hormone replacement your
body responds to what you do
if you go on a diet you lose weight if
you work out you get bigger
it's not like that without
the proper [ __ ] blood chemistry
it it [ __ ] it works before i went on
air hrt i work out there was some
response but then it got to the point to
where i could just work out nothing
would happen you just get tired you
wouldn't even hardly get sore
you know if you did get sore took
forever to heal up but you wouldn't get
any bigger
you wouldn't enhance at all
and it's because there's just there's
just
the testosterone isn't there
and it's in men and women just
different levels of it
[Music]
you could take that [ __ ] just on its own
and you get some response but you'd only
get about one-third of what you would
actually get if you you know if you
weren't lifting if you lift and
stress the body out it actually responds
because the chemistry's there
danny rolling ghostface says they say
that public gyms are dirtier than public
restrooms honestly probably sweat yeah i
don't doubt that yeah because honestly
public restrooms most places are
cleaning them once or twice a day
uh or maybe several times a day i know
like because i've had um you know i had
family members and [ __ ] like that that
worked in restaurants and they're like
yeah we cleaned the restrooms several
times so
they're probably pretty clean whereas
gyms
i kind of feel like a lot of that i'm
sure they clean them at the end of the
day especially nowadays because of covid
but
i kind of feel like maybe back in the
old days they'd be like well we're just
going to trust the people that use the
machines to like clean them off and i
kind of feel like a lot of people
probably don't do that the problem is
the sweat the
sweat can sometimes deposit
staff
that's yeah
staff
so honestly i was like i'll use my own
uh
you know stationary bike thank you
and i'll just i'll wipe it down after
everything and i'll put it back in the
gym and it'll be fine because i usually
it's weird because we have the gym which
is in the room over there but
it just seems it's easier because the
bike is light so i usually like carry
the bike in here every morning so i can
watch like [ __ ] on my laptop like a
documentary or something like while i'm
on there yeah the new the new bike and
then i carry it back in there i mean
it's heavy but it's not that heavy no
couple pounds so you know it's maybe 20
pounds maybe yeah
maybe 30 well an old gym an old bike
weighed a lot more like 60 yeah i mean
it's like i said it's heavy but it's not
so heavy that yeah you know so i just
kind of carry it in here every morning
do my however many miles i do
and while i'm watching some of my laptop
and then i put it back in the gym
because i don't want to leave it in here
because it'd be in the way but
because i usually use this laptop like
to watch stuff but yeah i don't
we had a remember we had that we had a
gym membership for a while and we did
actually go to that gym that was by our
old house yeah and
it just becomes a pain i don't like it
honestly the only thing with the
apartment that i lived in before
me and you started going out
the apartment that was over in winter
park
now that apartment complex had a little
gym of its own
and i actually quite liked using that
because most of the time because i
worked at night so i could use it during
the work day and nobody was in there
so
they didn't have a bunch of [ __ ] they
basically had an exercise bike they had
a treadmill they had a multi-gym and
they had a rack of like uh you know
barbells and stuff
and
you could go in there and fi and they
had a pool too so you could do laps and
whatnot
so
i liked to go in there like during the
weekdays because i didn't have to go to
work until five or six in the evening
and so i would go in there by myself but
if you have to go in a gym and there's
like people like watching you or you
like wait for the machines and [ __ ] that
no thanks most gyms make a living off of
people forgetting that they have the
membership yeah
that's why you gotta sign a contract
because they're like well most people
they for never come out particularly
like january but he's like man i'm gonna
lose some weight this year and they sign
up for a gym and then they they'll go a
couple times and they're like man [ __ ]
that it's like too much trouble yeah but
see that's why i like having the option
of
an exercise bike or something like that
in the house
because i know a lot of people buy
exercise equipment they don't use it
i will absolutely use it most gyms are
not real gems most gyms are it's there
people forget that they have the
membership it's always dead it makes
money off of you forgetting that you
have the membership
the people that are in there
like it
like uh uh they're eating pizza they're
eating free pizza and drinking free soda
there that they give out that was that
down what was the name of that planet
fitness planet fitness was fat cap and
they didn't they didn't encourage people
to
lose weight they were handing out free
[ __ ] people well i kind of feel like
their whole business model was we want
everybody to come in here and like not
just people that are
right so they were trying to like try
other things to get people that wouldn't
normally go to a gym yeah which didn't
really work
but you know it definitely didn't really
a real gym is [ __ ] a bunch of muscle
heads and girls that [ __ ] are into
muscle heads and really it's a steroid
distribution center that's what it is
that's a real gym you know over down in
muscle beach california it was the
prototype of them you had doctors
hanging out in there and they're selling
[ __ ] anabolic steroids to guys like
arnold schwarzenegger and [ __ ] it
cracks me i just think they're coming in
there and trench coats be like what do
you want kids and they just got like all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] well they were
bodybuilding the doctors were
bodybuilders too i know but yeah well i
like to imagine it one way i know that's
not the way it is that's not the way it
really was it really was i make [ __ ] up
for a living
but they made a [ __ ] ton of money
selling [ __ ] anabolic steroids this
is back in the 70s to uh other
bodybuilders and the ship was being made
in mexico most of it
across the border in tijuana and that's
really good [ __ ] there and uh
you know that's just the way that's just
the way the scene was and it still kind
of is
um
they're gonna have
the gym's gonna be in a damn
you might have a place like elite
fitness elite fitness they had one of
those a little private
gym and it was bikini girls and uh
richard is in there no just bikini girls
not with machine guns but
i don't know
cramps fans know what it is yeah they're
seen yeah but a real gym would be like
in a [ __ ] uh one of those damn rental
places there's all garages what do you
call those things an industrial park
yeah where it's garages except this one
one this one is a damn gym
and it's dark and it's got fans going
it's not even air conditioned and you go
in there and it's just [ __ ] roided
out [ __ ] muscle heads in there
they're [ __ ] huge
that's a real gem and that's a steroid
distribution center
go in there
buy anything you want
because they got steroid dealers in
there
but um
that's just the name of the game
and
i think i think everybody knows in
florida they're not real uh strict on it
because in florida you can go to an hrt
clinic here
and uh not only get [ __ ] uh test and
hcg you can get win straw you can get
any decades of rabbling they'll give you
anything they don't really care about it
john says i wanted to let you know tom i
fully agree with what you've said about
rifles and long guns i've been studying
ballistics and stuff who is this john
robertson that's the guy who was talking
yoga okay uh
studying bullet sticks and stuff since i
was 13 or so i wanted and still want to
do uh csi stuff okay i always kind of
wanted to do that too uh i'm just out a
lot more so a handgun may be more
convenient here's my thing man at your
age i'm going to [ __ ] kind of push
you away from handguns
you get your handgun you're going to get
[ __ ] tempted to carry it
and if you're tempted to carry it you're
going to be probably not going to have a
ccw
and then uh and if you do have a even if
you did have a ccw
somebody's gonna [ __ ] with you and
you're gonna [ __ ] man up and bow up
and shoot a [ __ ] the next thing
you know you're gonna be in jail and
it'd probably be better to take the ass
weapon than it would be to go through
all that legal trouble of [ __ ]
gacking somebody over a minor dispute
because
typically it's a minor minor dispute
if the trouble is real
you're gonna want a [ __ ] rifle
real trouble is usually happening at
your house home invasion
or uh or your neighbor is in [ __ ]
serious trouble and your
europeans like what the [ __ ] is going on
in the united states
in most places look
law enforcement response could take a
half hour 45 minutes you're on your
[ __ ] own
out here this is not
city this is country
in um
in mississippi out in heidelberg in
those areas uh you have two cops a night
cop and a day cop
if you call him depending on where you
are in heidelberg it might be [ __ ] 20
30 minutes before a policeman shows up
and he's going to be somebody who's kind
of sub-standard
in training and ability
in the united states [ __ ] you take
care of yourself all right that's real
that's that's the reality
uh if you were up in a place like canada
even more so most of canada's [ __ ]
frozen tundra there's only three cities
in canada when you really think about it
and uh if you got into trouble in canada
you're on your [ __ ] own
rifles the way to go
for home defense in most of the most of
the united states
most of the united states is not urban
most of it is not suburban most of its
rural
police response is [ __ ] long time and
there's all kinds of granters whose ex
retired policeman right there
will tell you
there is a [ __ ] ton of stuff going on in
the rural areas of the united states
police are never involved it's solved by
people just out there in the [ __ ]
wild like back out in the old west
now within reason we're not talking
about
liquor store robberies or we're not
talking about that we're talking about
their [ __ ] that's been gone down between
families that live out in the middle of
nowhere that are enemies
uh [ __ ]
somebody attacks somebody out in the
middle of nowhere it kills that person
they never find anybody
just a missing person forever
never found
the us is a cool place to live but you
even out in the rural areas you gotta
[ __ ]
have the ability to protect yourself
just the way it is
and it's always been that way
geography is dictating reality out here
not laws
okay i'm done done saying
uh murder hornet return says jenny white
year was flesh for frankenstein i'm
trying to download it 1973 although i've
seen some places call it 1974.
uh oh and then he says never mind found
it
pretty sure it came out in 1973.
although i think it's on shutter
but i think on shuttered it says 1974
but i think it actually came out in 1973
so you know
um i might need another drink okay
yeah yeah
is pookie still sleeping over there yeah
she's over there oh my god i came in but
i didn't even realize she's been sitting
there's a chair over there by the she's
by the bar
and uh yeah she's she's like
i came out of the bathroom and i was
like hey pook and she was like
hey don't touch me it's very comfortable
out here don't touch me very secure i
mean she hangs out
in this office
pretty much every single day
i mean i come in here and work and
she'll like jump on my desk and
fart around and like step on my keyboard
and be like hey pet me what do you just
like stop looking at the [ __ ] screen
just
like sticks your butt so i can't you
know see the screen i'm like looking
around her like that and then she's like
what are you doing then she lays down
then she tries to like tear up my papers
and pushes my pen off the desk and [ __ ]
like that
but then after a while she settles down
and
falls asleep in the chair usually that
one over there but sometimes that one
over there too and she's sleeping in
that chair yeah we're talking about you
she's like what okay
man i don't know what the [ __ ] she was
doing last night but
i woke up at
i think it was 4am or something like
that and i heard
and i was like what the [ __ ] she like
runs up and down the hall
from the bedroom
i don't know what i don't know what
she's doing
and i'd i think i said this before but i
bought her this like toy for christmas
that's one of those it's like four
levels and it's like these little balls
and these little
uh you know
these little [ __ ] i don't know but
they like go around like that
and you you know you can kind of kick
him around and for whatever reason
she likes to play with it but she only
likes to play with it when no one's
looking at her
so it's like sometimes you'll wake up at
like three in the morning and you hear
or playing with it because it's a very
distinctive sound
and then if you get up like to go to the
bathroom or something you look in there
like both of her hands will be on the
ball but then she'll look at you like oh
[ __ ] like i got busted like she's not
supposed to be playing with it or she's
like embarrassed to be playing with it i
don't really know it's like the [ __ ]
craziest [ __ ] ever
but yeah oh look at her she's crazy
also
uh
i don't know what her deal was last
night either she kept wanting we buy her
these little uh
what are they uh sheba makes them and
they're like little meat sticks
and
she [ __ ] loves those and tom keeps
them in the drawer
in the uh you know the nightstand like
next to his side of the bed
and she knows they're in there
so a lot of times she'll come up to the
side of the bed and then she'll start
like [ __ ] with stuff like she'll go
up on the nightstand like push stuff off
or she'll like start scratching at the
wall or something like that and then
she'll like sit there and like look at
him
or look at the drawer and then look at
him and look at the drawer and look at
him and he's just like oh okay i see
what you want so he has to like get him
out but then
you you give him to her and then she'll
like she'll eat half and then she's like
okay i'll eat the rest of it later i
don't know
it's [ __ ] funny
john gore says 73 was a good year for
horror and porn
i agree
i agree
70s just kind of underrated when it came
to uh oh i don't want to say porn
because some of that porn [ __ ] sucked
i mean [ __ ] we don't like all
that pubic hair but they were beautiful
people in the 70s uh the fashion was
kind of cool if you looked at men's
magazines from the 70s you know playboy
penthouse hustler that kind of [ __ ] they
had some really good looking models back
then and
you didn't see
as much uh you know plastic surgery
implants and things that they were
natural looking so if a girl had big
boobs she was gonna be in there it was
just a different time but yeah they had
some really good looking models but you
know that goes all the way back to the
uh 60s and the 50s you know i mean they
there were some pin-up girls from the
50s were just looking gorgeous 40s too
um
the thing is is a lot of it doesn't
survive because uh there was anti-porn
kind of laws 40s and 50s so it was
they were all pin up girls from
private collections from the california
era
area
they would do little photo shoots and
guys would take pictures of them and
they would trade these pictures
between each other um
weird when you think about it but i
guess i mean they were making stag
movies like way back in the day honestly
one time when i was in new york that was
also private collections most of us yeah
i was in new york in the 2000s 2000
late 2000s
and uh
i went to the museum of sex which is a
great museum if you guys have ever been
there if you go to new york city go
there it's like super fun
and when i was there one of the um kind
of limited time displays they had was
like stag films from the 1930s
and the way they had it all set up was
really cool because they were like
projecting them all over the floor and
[ __ ] like that
and i actually have a dvd somewhere i
think i bought it in new york too i
think i bought it at like uh one of
those like old school like record stores
that held those old like cult movies and
[ __ ] and there was like uh they had all
these like stag movies from the 30s and
it's like
people talk about porn nowadays it's
like that was just it's obviously the uh
you know the production values aren't as
high
um you know and it's just normal looking
girls
you know they don't have plastic surgery
or anything like that
but
i mean the [ __ ] was just as like dirty
as [ __ ] nowadays yeah you know so
don't
don't be thinking like
thank you tom i understand what you mean
you know your stuff and i highly value
your opinion uh thank you when i become
king of the world i want you as my war
general position is open
i will be the immortal i will be your
boy
uh yeah i don't i just don't recommend
pistols for young guys man i just don't
you guys are a little [ __ ] hot-headed
um i had them before i went into service
1911's a lot of them and and 586s which
you probably know what those are um and
um
man you're
as a young guy you're real tempted to
carry something like that and
you don't want to carry something like
that unless it's kind of your job all
right
young guys really shouldn't be trusted
with much of anything i disagree
young guys i'm mo i'm being facetious
a young guy is suitable to be in a
military or in law enforcement where
you've had proper training and
discipline
and your
um desire for action and adventure is
being challenged channeled increa in a
creative
in a creative direction that helps your
civilization
you on your own out there
[ __ ] with a gun in your [ __ ]
pocket
um you you're gonna run into a situation
and
you're probably gonna go for that gun
instead of with it probably could have
been solved
by other means fists or [ __ ] words
can sometimes solve some of that the
chances of you being randomly attacked
by an armed attacker and killed pretty
slim at your age being a man
a woman might be a different story but
wonder where you live yes a man
no
not saying
you can't have a pistol okay just that
you're gonna be tempted to carry it i
would recommend a rifle first and
work with the rifle and learn everything
about rifles
uh go shoot them you're not gonna be
tempted to carry it you stay you take it
home now when you start getting in your
30s you're a little more level-headed
yeah you can get your pistol you can get
your pistol and if you feel like for
some reason you need your own security
go get a ccw and you can carry it
legally do not carry dirty
carrying dirty or owning things and
carrying dirty or asking for [ __ ]
jail time man
and
you're gonna get jail time over
something that's a minor
thing you know
statistics have a lot to do with what
i'm talking about
now if we lived in afghanistan
or if we lived in
mos iceland spaceport in [ __ ] star
wars
then yeah okay that's a different
situation but for now
for now the [ __ ] average situation
for the average place in the united
states
a guy your age of your profile shouldn't
be walking
shouldn't really be
walking around with a pistol
okay just that's just my
and most dudes don't
they just don't yeah i mean i really
don't like as a woman i don't really
like the thought of that yeah now
pistol in your pistol in your [ __ ]
car
yeah a lot of states that's like that
when it's permitted
but
why does it have to be a pistol if it's
in your car it could also be a rifle
you know and a lot of guys are carrying
[ __ ] truck guns that's a totally
different situation and you know if you
needed a truck gun because you're in
your truck and some [ __ ] goes down then
the pistol's the last thing you want you
wanted the rifle to begin with
a small foldable rifle with a short
barrel they're calling those pistols now
like a little [ __ ] foldable jackal 10
inch jackal or an a or a [ __ ]
collapsible stock 10 inch or a
collapsible
hand brace 10 inch [ __ ] ar
yeah okay or a little [ __ ]
collapsible arm brace [ __ ] 10 inch ak
crank off style
yeah that's good for a truck gun because
those were made for vehicles to begin
with armored vehicles in the soviet army
you know or helicopter type that's good
you could have that if these are
security type
firearms
carrying concealed that's what a pistol
is for to carry a hidden weapon on your
body
it's seductive when you're a young guy
to carry that
into a place
here
that could cause trouble the cops aren't
gonna like it okay they're just not as
granters he's in the [ __ ] comment
section i'm talking about statistics
statistically
pistols are for carried concealed and if
you don't have a carry concealed permit
you really don't need one
you don't need one
carrying on a holster
yeah okay if you have an open carry
situation some states allow open carry
you can go that way that's not carrying
concealed
big
different situation very different
you you got a [ __ ] pistol on a
holster you're on a
run to the [ __ ]
depositing money or you're [ __ ]
there's a damn riot going on or
something then maybe yeah i mean but
nah if you need a gun that's gonna you
need to go for a rifle
that's a real [ __ ] weapon
and it'll keep you out of trouble
because you can't hide it
john gore says devil and miss jones is a
hell of a movie it is i agree
it is it's a classic i mean come on
um danny really good space has great
connection tonight so far i know i
wasn't interested i was trying to like
not to think about it because i thought
that maybe it would like jinx it but
maybe it's maybe it's okay maybe it's
okay
beasley says just uploaded she freak
from 1967.
um you know
i'm kind of into like i i don't know i
i like horror movies
uh from every era
but there's something about 70s ones
even when they're bad
that there's some i don't know it's like
some weird kind of like vibe to them i
guess because it maybe because it
reminds me of being a kid i don't really
know what it is
but
70s horror movies especially like 70s
haunted house movies
i'm all about that yeah there's just
something about that whole vibe to it
even if it sucks it's like still pretty
good
i don't know
hornets asked me something about some of
the but what is it something there we go
goes in the buttstock what do you say
everything goes um
does it remember the rifle you remember
those 22 rifles where all the parts fit
in the stock
yeah yeah the ar7
that was a eugene stoner designs
blowback 22 ar7 that started off as a
survival rifle for uh that they were
going to put in the injection seats of
[ __ ] fighter pilot
uh
kits
if once you hit the ejection seat you
came out with that thing
they weren't bad they just weren't great
either they're around
they would float too everything would go
into stock and you could throw it in the
water it would float
they had a bunch of different kits for
it
i remember it
i drink your blood is great too yeah i
kind of feel like well that was always
like on a double bill with it was i
drink your blood and i eat your skin
those two movies were like always they
were at the drive-in like in the 70s i
like actually both of those movies i
like a lot of those really shitty cheap
like i said i just i don't know there's
just something about that [ __ ] vibe
man and i kind of feel like particularly
back in the 60s and 70s i mean it's not
like nowadays and i'm not you know
[ __ ] on nowadays because i think
it's awesome that you know people that
want to make movies can actually make a
decent movie for
almost nothing like nowadays
and they have done
back in the 60s and 70s you had to
[ __ ] commit you really had to want to
make a movie
uh because you had to like pay for
actual cameras you couldn't just make
the [ __ ] on your iphone
uh you know and you had to like pay for
all that stuff
and
so i'm willing to forgive a lot of the
[ __ ] because
you know you really really wanted to
make this movie it's like it's
unfortunate that it came out the way it
came out
and i'm
i don't know why but i'm thinking in
particular of like [ __ ] blood waters
of dr z or zat uh which is was also
released as there's some [ __ ]
in florida that were like we're gonna
make some like
thing that they kind of wanted to be
creature from the black lagoon but
they made it for like a buck 98
and uh
and it's terrible
but
i still respect that though because at
least you still you still had to pay for
the cameras you still had to pay for
like some semblance of crew i'd imagine
and uh it was much harder back then you
couldn't really get distribution you
actually had to make a film
you know not like nowadays like i said
where everything's kind of shot on
digital you can make
perfectly uh you know perfectly good
movies on a [ __ ] phone
uh you couldn't do that back then so you
really had to commit and honestly i
don't know if that makes it sadder
though because it's like you really had
to commit to like yeah we spent 68
thousand dollars and this movie just
looks like
ass
it is just terrible
but i'm willing to give him some leeway
plus like i don't know there's something
about the 70s ones that i just i love i
don't know i like the vibe of it
uh murder hornet return says i drink
your blood was better i agree
uh i your skin was okay but
you know
it's it
uh coach raylo says the women the women
were very natural in the 70s 60s and 70s
i prefer the older photos of hot woman
from this era yeah it um
i was kind of like i remember being in
barnes and noble like several years ago
and seeing like this there was this book
that was like old uh playboy
spreads like from the 60s and 70s and
one thing that struck me not so much the
pube pair because i knew about that but
i forgot about like the tan lines yeah i
thought it was sexy actually yeah so a
lot of them did have like tan lines
which they would never do nowadays even
if if a model had tan lines now they
would photoshop that [ __ ] out they
photoshop
because you know i've been using
photoshop for more than 20 years
uh every model that you see on the front
of a magazine or whatever the [ __ ]
um they lengthen their
uh torso
they make their uh thighs skinnier
they even out all their skin i mean the
million things that they do to those
pictures
would blow your [ __ ] mind like all
the [ __ ] that they do to those people
and it's just really funny because i
kind of feel like some actresses uh you
know several years back
i'm thinking like i think like several
years ago like kate winslet came out and
there was like a picture of her that was
on the cover of i don't remember what it
was rolling stone or some movie magazine
or something and she was just kind of
like that's like not even me she's like
that's not even what that movie because
they stretched her out they made like
her
her waist skinnier like her thigh
skinner she's like that is not what i
look like so
to me it's always been obvious that
they're that they do that yeah because i
i can draw the human form i was begging
to [ __ ] sketch it out and [ __ ] you
know
and you can tell you know yeah and me
being all into [ __ ] human physique
and [ __ ] bodybuilding and stuff you
can see when the when the proportions
are not right
but
for some reason the general public i
guess they don't look at people like
cows or horses or you know they're
anatomy magazines they're not real
analytical about it they're more i guess
emotional they just accept what they see
you're like
well that's hot but that's not what she
looks like they look like that leg is
about [ __ ] one quarter of a length
too [ __ ] long yeah it's usually not
real um
the proportions are not correct but they
do change the proportion slightly to
make them look one thing that they for
sure do yeah they they for sure stretch
out the torso the shin bones they tend
to make them longer that too uh there's
the fingers and then they make the
fingers longer and then they make they
make the waist far slimmer than it can
be it can only be that slim if it was
corseted they'll do [ __ ] like that
um they do things to the faces that are
like they'll remove any kind of
blemishes from the faces and a lot of
shading and
nobody wants to see a mole
jesus christ but um god forbid we're all
[ __ ] human beings yeah
with imperfections it's more art
yeah and i get that um you know i but
trying to sell a product yeah and just
have an artful photograph of a human
form there on on
uh instagram i follow a channel i think
it's called photos 50 60 70s
i think is i believe what the name of it
is and it's and whoever runs that is
[ __ ] great instagram channel
and they're just digging up these
[ __ ] great photographs of i think i
follow that as well beautiful women from
that era and they're they're not nudes
or or if they are nudes or tasteful
nudes but they're mostly semi nudes uh
playboy penthouse um
[ __ ] pinup girls going back to the
ages and you just be amazed at how
one how tastes changed over the years
and um
how photography changed but you also
kind of stunned by
how
human beauty is a constant
is that what people thought think is
beautiful now they always thought it was
beautiful and that [ __ ]
the beauties of today are not very
unique uh that was always around well
yeah that's what i mean if you look at
like you know the the beautiful actors
or actresses from the 1920s yeah they're
still around
i mean you would still look at a picture
and be like yeah that's a beautiful
person like it wouldn't be like some
weird like what the [ __ ] were they
thinking it's not it's not like that
that's still like another thing that'll
strike you is you'll see photographs
from the 50s and the 40s of uh well in
in that case of this channel it's women
of beautiful women from the
40s and 50s but you and they're american
but you realize that they're also ethnic
that so that a lot of these are mexican
girls or bl or black girls or
uh mixed girls that they had all that
back then um
it was not this uh
[ __ ] um
you know
totally
white caucasians you just didn't see
that in the main stream um you saw that
a lot in erotica yeah
um i think the 40s the united states was
97 white i think is what it said on
paper whether or not that was actually
true i don't know i kind of doubt that
i kind of kind of doubt that too that
seems very high i think there must have
been even for the
i think 1940s i believe it claimed it
was 97 white
but there was probably a lot of
illegal what you call the illegal aliens
yeah i kind of feel like there was a lot
of people that maybe like were not
reporting that they were always here
because like if you look at if you look
at florida
i've heard people that are not from
florida
go yeah but then there's all those
hispanics that have moved in like what
do you tell what are you talking about
they've always been here they were here
before we were here before the united
states
they didn't come forward
florida was the [ __ ] spanish empire
well it's [ __ ] most of the united states
was owned by mexico like that whole
[ __ ] portion
and here's another thing that [ __ ] a
lot of people don't realize yeah the
mexican army left
but the mexican civilians that were here
didn't they didn't leave they were
stayed here it's like look this is my
[ __ ] house right yeah so there's this
when the american army came came in
uh and it started to expand westward
during the
mexican-american war
the mexican army that was here
guarding the area was very sparse i mean
the the military presence was next to
nothing
we ran in here and said this is now ours
because it was all [ __ ] contested
mexi mexico believed it was their
territory because they picked up
the claim from spain after the
mexican after this
after the mexican revolution against
spain
the mexican government said anything
spain claimed is now ours but these are
all claims from european empires those
claims didn't mean anything there every
time you looked around everybody had a
different damn map and everybody was
saying that north america was theirs
you had to fight for it and get in there
and occupy it to say
we are here it is ours it was all
contested
you had native americans but they didn't
have a centralized government and they
had been warring with each other for
[ __ ] thousands of years
and because they had no means of [ __ ]
making any kind of
of what do you call it
uh uh diplomatic arrangements with any
kind of empires and they didn't have the
money to fight european empires then the
native americans were never going to
have a [ __ ] i mean even if they did
would anybody have listened to them
anyways because
each
tribe was only like between five and ten
thousand people which is sad that's not
enough people like what we've been here
for like ten thousand years that doesn't
count for anything yeah okay well it was
kind of like uh
kind of like uh germa germania in the
roman era there's nothing but german
tribes
fighting each other there were only a
few thousand of each one of the tribes
like the helvetii and all these other
ones
you know it was back when we were tribal
that's that's the level they were at so
they couldn't really tell a european
empire that uh our tribe of 10 000
people has claimed to this area
they would just laugh at that they're
like that's not enough not enough you
know you
where it's we're a tribe of millions and
we have this and that and we have guns
and whole armies and [ __ ] tons of gold
and ships and [ __ ] word we are an
empire and you guys aren't [ __ ]
this is our land
land only belongs to people who have the
[ __ ]
the means to take it
we don't live in a world of right and
wrong or fairness it's all about power
and when you really get down to its
power
and most of the power springs from money
money and gold
so uh anyway to get back to what i was
talking about
when the mexican army kind of retreated
they didn't take their civilians with
them they [ __ ] owned that land
okay they had houses and all kinds of
[ __ ] and farms
and it's not like they met the american
government kicked them out they let them
stay
so even from the very beginning a lot of
these uh states that have large
mexican-american type populations their
their ancestors were here
pre-united states yeah and they kind of
became de facto american citizens as
soon as as soon as the
north the the western part of north
america was annexed basically
which is that's the old school way to do
it you just take the [ __ ] they're like
okay we're in charge now y'all can stay
good everything's good
your army guys have to go back to
[ __ ] mexico city okay
and it just changed hands
it was kind of like that with florida
um
the seminoles were involved there was
three different seminole wars and king
osceola
and all his guys got sent to oklahoma
which they didn't like that because they
had to settle next to the crow and they
hated the crow or the creek the creek
indians they didn't like the creek
indians
the seminoles and the creeks were kind
of like the english and the french they
were traditional enemies and one of the
reasons why king osceola and the
seminoles didn't want to surrender is
they did not want to live next to creek
up in up in oklahoma
that's a whole story in themselves but
osceola is still honored here in the
florida
to this day because
he wouldn't surrender
yeah i mean they're i wouldn't have
surrendered either
i don't know about i don't know if you
guys know but there are in florida um
there are a bunch of like there's a
county there's a whole bunch of like
schools and [ __ ] like that that are
named after yola yeah
i mean
went over i didn't go i went to tomoka
elementary which is another native
american name but one of our one of the
other elementary schools in this area
was osceola
there's a lot of stuff and there's an
osceola county i think too yeah so a lot
of shift [ __ ] is named after him yeah
when osceola and the very last of the of
the seminoles when they when they got
deported
because they didn't want to accept
american citizenship
oh the other ones did that's the thing
that i think it was uh 15 000 possible i
think it was 15 000. that's how many
seminoles there were at that point
in the other two seminal wars the other
seminoles became american citizens it
gets kind of confusing people think
everything is cut and dried black and
white
a lot of people rolled and became
american citizens it wasn't really in
their advantage to
to maintain a tribal identity
because
the the situation back in those days
was if you wanted to maintain
if you wanted to live inside the borders
of the united states you had to become
an american citizen you couldn't be a
tribal citizen you couldn't have a
country within another country
you didn't have to be an american
citizen but if you wanted to remain
america an indian you had to go to what
was called indian territory
which was that was a they're asking a
lot of them then when you think about it
because they had to live with their
enemies
that'd be like grabbing some people from
england saying we were going to move you
to france
yeah well that's what i mean and i kind
of feel like there was a there was a
perception
that when you talk about native
americans that it was just this one like
monolithic and it's not it's like europe
it yeah it was a bunch of different
nations and some of them hated each
other yeah they were so thousands of
years just like a regular nation one so
it's kind of like
yeah we don't really like being like
grouped into the same group as these
[ __ ] because we hate these
[ __ ] and like why you know so i
don't know and a lot and they weren't
the same race they all had different
ethnic groups up in the northeast they
were people walking across the ice shelf
from europe
and what they call the clovis people and
you know that ended up being you know
kind of like canadian and northeastern
type native americans and
according to the witnesses of the time
they looked awful european at that time
and then the ones down in the
southwest looked very mexican because
like mexican indians because that's
that's who they were related to and
other ones looked a little bit more kind
of like chinese and
when you go down into even further south
and central america because you know you
guys know that i grew up in brazil too
when you went down a real far south
american
according to those statues those people
looked very polynesian maybe even
african
the statues that survived have african
features on them
and africans were [ __ ]
seafaring a lot of people don't realize
that but man in the prehistoric era
africans got on boats
and it would not shock me if they were
like
discovered stuff like before europeans
discover so it could be that
people like the toll tech people might
have had a lot of african roots to them
wouldn't surprise me at all
sorry we were talking about the movies
before we were talking about how uh i
eat your skin and i drink your blood and
then gg maniac says triple feature with
i thumb through your magazines
[Laughter]
followed by i steal food from your
fridge yeah i would watch that movie not
gonna lie
um dj maniac also says i preferred the
60s look on women
uh i like the eye makeup from the 60s to
be honest with you i like that
kind of like that upper
cat eye wing thing with like the fake
uh lashes
and nothing underneath i do like that
look i kind of like the big hair from
the 60s too although
it's kind of a pain it has to do khan of
the nation of atslan is talking about
the future nation of atlan he's talking
about something that's on apple tv it's
called foundation
it's similar to the dude
it's an isaac asimov
oh i've heard that
i don't know about it yeah
sounds good i might have read that
actually now that i'm thinking about it
yeah um i don't have access to apple tv
i don't think i don't have it
one of these days yeah uh joe nash says
the reference to little joe and the song
walk on the wild side is about joe
d'alessandro honestly i meant to mention
that in our flesh or frankenstein review
and i might have forgotten and i feel
really bad about that now because that
was one of the things that i did
actually want to mention because i did
mention
that joe d'alessandro was the crotch
on rolling stone sticky fingers
album cover
and he was also on the cover of the
first smith's album that was him
uh but yeah he was also talked about
because like i said he was a very
uh
kind of a big like underground figure
around that time period so
you know
very big cult figure not a great actor
gotta say
but
he looked good so i guess he didn't
really have to worry about anything
uh
other than that
what was the other thing
uh tammy says the problem is young girls
don't realize the models are being
photoshopped get bad self-esteem i kind
of hope
i would hope that nowadays because i
kind of feel like that was a bigger
problem
my generation and maybe the generation
following where maybe they weren't aware
of what you could do with photoshop no
no but nowadays i think maybe they know
so i do kind of feel like
i've seen some funny [ __ ] nowadays
though because some people
who don't really know how to use
photoshop although or don't have the
patience for it or whatever and they
will
take a picture of themselves and they'll
try to like you whatever like make their
butt look bigger and make their thighs
look smaller and they'll do it like uh
in a really like half-assed
like really like [ __ ]
quick sort of way
and
it looks uh not good so
i mean if you know what you're doing
you can make it look real but that takes
a very very long time to do a very long
time but uh oh he's got his [ __ ] yeah
i'm going straight kodan he's going cody
well straight glenn danziger yeah i was
gonna say glen dancing
and i think that kind of like when i was
a kid
um i think it bothered me more when i
was a kid because i didn't realize until
i got older and like learned about
photography and photoshop and stuff like
that
i kind of thought you know
these girls that you see in these photos
it's like they look perfect
but and even like back in the 70s and
80s when they didn't have the technology
that they have now they had ways of
doing it though but they did still have
ways of doing it i mean now it's much
easier now it's much easier yeah back in
those days the airbrush but they were
doing it back then too yeah and i guess
and you know much like some people i
didn't really realize so i'm just kind
of like why don't i look like that like
what the [ __ ] what's the matter with me
so it just
i mean it is sucky but i do kind of feel
like nowadays people are a lot more
cognizant yeah well what you can do with
the technology let's defend the those
those models from that era still were
gorgeous they just made them look even
super naturally gorgeous
they were good-looking that's what i
mean yeah yeah and like i said nobody's
saying that they're taking like somebody
that looks like a total complete like
[ __ ] toad
or something like that and making yeah
you need something like you need a
foundation to work from yeah uh you
can't
i mean all you gotta do is look at it is
it possible sure but it would take way
longer i mean honestly
the better looking the person is that
you start out with the much easier it is
to make them look like supernaturally
beautiful can you make an ugly person
look good in a photo sure yeah but it's
gonna but it's gonna take a lot longer
yeah a lot longer
so
you know i'm just saying and i'm not
saying that that doesn't mean that those
women were hot of course they were
but i'm just saying that
it's much you know it
nowadays it's much easier to take out
everybody's
like slightest perfection and algorithms
can do it well that's what i mean yeah
it's just so easy program do it easy
like i said
honestly yeah i have like filters in my
photoshop to just kind of like hey let's
like let's do a facial smoothing yeah
you know what i mean it's like it's
super easy so it's like let's get rid of
like every single zit and every single
mole and every single imperfection those
other ones that can elongate you that
too
and that's what i mean and it's like
i don't know that's still kind of shitty
it's still good it's just taking
pictures nobody cares i know but you
know it's so it proliferates so much
nowadays that i don't really think
anything i don't care about other
people's self-esteem
if you haven't figured out that you can
twist a photo and do anything you want
then then
we're not talking about like people that
are like old like you we're talking
about like kids
well kids know kids know even more but
like i said kids nowadays probably no
yeah but kids when i was growing up did
not right so you know so that was kind
of like it does kind of sucky and
honestly like when you grow up
thinking that
um and not knowing that it does kind of
like linger into your adulthood that's
what i'm saying
uh let's see what did you do
kind of outside talk about taxes what do
you say about texas
tom do you see texas going their own way
what uh it's kind of spelling is weird
okay what i know is that texas was an
independent nation joined the us so can
they leave whenever they want yeah yeah
texas
texas claims in their constitution that
they can leave the union anytime they
want
but that's kind of that's kind of a moot
point
if texas decided to leave the union it
would be happening in a world where
pretty much everyone was leaving a union
but they would leave the union to form
new unions
um and
people get upset when they [ __ ] hear
about [ __ ] like this but there's
childish
attachments to names
into concepts
countries and empires have certain
lifespan they have certain life cycles
just like human beings there's childhood
there's [ __ ]
teenage years there's young adult and
then there's [ __ ] middle age and then
there's old age and death
and if you look throughout history
countries and empires do the same thing
uh
the the american empire as it is right
now
uh yeah it looks like its time is island
it is short i'm not really worried about
it though because um
uh the us being divided up into states
and the way the whole thing is [ __ ]
set
set up from the very beginning
uh we're kind of a modular country
a
the
washington dc could disintegrate and it
would reorganize
it would reorganize quickly and it
wouldn't be very traumatic for the
united states
would be nowhere near as traumatic as
say like the soviet union falling apart
the soviet union wasn't set up like us
it took them decades to recover
the united states could do it in a
couple of years it wouldn't matter
because each state is almost like an
independent country
um
it would be a rough
year or so
be like coming off a heroin
because there is some [ __ ] things
that banks and corporations do to these
states to keep them
kind of dependent
and to keep them kind of like under a
thumb of a [ __ ] kind of a top-down
banking system uh
when i think about it it's mostly the
banking system that kind of worries me
but i think that would work out too
banking systems
federal reserve bank kind of
but in an era of [ __ ] cryptocurrency
the
all that shit's [ __ ]
a lot easier to deal with now
nature would take its course it would
smooth itself out in a couple years i'm
not worried about it gotta say though
like texas been crying about like
leaving for i don't even remember how
long i remember that [ __ ] from when i
was a kid i was just like so go then
take your ball and go home if you're
they're not going to do it well
california is saying they're going to
leave that's what i mean i mean
everybody everybody's not going to do it
uh well
it could if they do it
that's not what i said too
i said i know what you said if if if
texas leaves it's because the whole
thing is breaking up
all right
because
you have to understand some people think
that these states are dependent on a
central government they're not
texas geographically is twice the size
of germany
it's
twice it has twice the gdp of russia
and half the people
okay
texas
texas if you actually looked at texas
texas would be a [ __ ] very serious
country on its own
if there was no union texas could whip
any other state's ass in this union it
would
uh florida would be
better than than say
um
england by far
be on par with japan probably
or maybe uh
be like that
it's uh because i live in florida i
don't care i don't care what happens um
but yeah [ __ ] could happen the soviet
union fell apart overnight i watched it
happen i was on duty when it happened
um
i wouldn't even worry about the military
ramifications the u.s the u.s army and
its military is immaterial obsolete by
the day standards who cares
even the nuclear arsenal i don't care
about it it would it would be divided up
or destroyed and we make another one
i don't care none of it matters
empires have been doing this forever
if i were to say anything would happen
the united states would eventually break
into two break into two same the roman
empire did an eastern and a western
empire you'd have a blue empire and a
red-eye empire
that's all
wouldn't matter
not to me
john gore says
joe d'alessandro was supposed to be
michael corleone he was up for the part
but they went with pacino honestly i'm
glad they went with pacino though
because
joe d'alessandro uh despite his
uh obvious physical charms
not an actor
gonna say
i mean you know
i i really did i enjoyed him in flesh
for frankenstein but i enjoyed him
because he was like a blank void of a
human being which i thought was very
funny and i also kind of loved the
brooklyn accent contrasted against all
of the
clearly european
[ __ ] that was going on i thought that
was very amusing
but
i will admit that i haven't seen paul
morrissey's other stuff with him in it
okay like flesh and heat and all that
um i've seen like clips of them but i've
never like watched them all the way
through so i do but he does really seem
like a non-actor
so i don't know how well that would have
worked in the godfather so just saying
um
you know that's you know he he looks
fine connor ozlon says also saw just uh
prisoners of ghostlane yeah we watched
that too nicolas cage i didn't uh love
it i don't know i love nicolas cage not
gonna say that it looked awesome i don't
know for whatever reason i don't know if
i just wasn't in the mood for it or
i just couldn't get into it i couldn't
get into it it seemed very
[Music]
i don't know it seemed kind of like uh
you tom compared it to that [ __ ] show
what's that [ __ ] show uh into the
badlands which i never super like i feel
like i should have been able to get into
that show but i just couldn't
i don't know i couldn't get into it i
couldn't connect with it and i kind of
feel like maybe that's what happened
with prisoners of ghostline too because
it seemed like a cool idea
it's just that
and i liked parts of it but
i don't know i couldn't get into it i
wasn't like super engaged that's all um
i'll try to like watch it again at some
point because you know
dj maniac says you're aware that with
the advances with hgtv we're seeing a
lot more full frontal nudity in old
films now because the lighting has been
corrected yet
probably and
honestly i kind of feel like did
somebody like say this
later cheryl says i watch blood for
dracula this afternoon not as fun as
flash flesh or frankenstein i kind of
perceived that i i remember liking blood
for dracula but i think flesh for
frankenstein being the first one was
like way more over the top and therefore
more fun dji maniacal says there's two
things you never want to watch in hd
wrestling and porn yeah i kind of do not
want to see everyone's pores
and nose hairs
and [ __ ] like that you don't really want
to
why would you want to see that
nothing everything does not have to be
in high definition
something should not be you know
mr x uh hercules says women in the 70s
were hot the bell-bottom jeans and the
front bangs on the hair
yeah i'm into it the thing is though is
that people talk about 70s fashion there
were two 70s fashions if you go back to
the movies and look
there was white 70s fashion and it was
black 70s fashions
the pants that white girls wore in the
70s were higher waist and
it the bell to the bottom started at the
upper thigh
it didn't look that good
black girl bell bottoms were [ __ ] hip
huggers
and the bell started below the knee it
looked a lot better
well yeah because it's like it's going
to make the like the bottom of your legs
look wider and your thighs look a lot
better because they were tight all right
black girls work tight thigh pants with
the things you'll check that
people think that all bell bottoms were
the same and they weren't go back in
those movies and look
well black girls wore looked a lot
better than what white girls wore in the
70s
and that was the that was black girl
fashion it looked better
well that's why if you see kind of like
quote unquote blaxploitation films from
the seven years a lot better uh yeah
their clothes are a lot more like
awesome than the the white ones and the
white girls yeah
green blackie the scream the real good
fashion well made even the shitty ones
like the [ __ ] uh like you know uh the
petey wheat straw and all that kind of
like [ __ ] yeah
which i guess you know dolomite all that
kind of stuff we're kind of mixing it
all together
we're kind of mixing it all together
like 70s fashion was all the same it
wasn't it was ethnic
black girl 70s fashion was better than
white girl 70s fashion it just was the
cuts were better but i guess white girls
thought that was too revealing or
it was just too too much it was very
strange and i and we've kind of like cut
maybe like
you know talked about this before but i
feel like in a lot of 70s movies
and i was watching this occurred to me i
was watching [ __ ] laser blast which
was on mst i don't watch it on its own
because don't watch it on its own it's
insufferable but on mst it was good
in that movie like the main character's
mom
was wearing what i consider kind of like
70s white woman fashion
one she was like coke or skinny yeah
like i don't even know how she got into
those [ __ ] pants and the pants were
super tight no vpl no nothing you know
what i mean and
holy [ __ ] like how the [ __ ] and they
even made jokes about it like how the
[ __ ] like does she eat yeah i don't
really get it
now it's all kind of kind of
white girl 70 fashion
was kind of more like a coke or injencos
if you know what jenkos were
they were kind of like small jankos
which i thought jenkos were cute when
they came out jinkos were like each
[ __ ] pant leg was almost like a skirt
okay but as with everything else yeah it
depends on who's wearing it yeah it
depends on his right hand they were kind
of low rise they were kind of head
buggers
but um
white girl 70s fashion were kind of like
jenkos but they were high-waisted and
they they were unflattering made your
[ __ ] ass look long and skinny
and even if you weren't even if you
didn't have a belly it made you look
like you had a belly
black black girl's 70s was [ __ ] low
rise hip huggers tight along the thigh
under the knee then it bailed out
and then usually the bell bottom wasn't
very long it stopped at the ankle so you
could wear a boot and they had usually
platform boots they look good it looks a
lot better
and
more
ass more thigh appearance more midriff
they tend not to show midriff
white girls from the 70s didn't
but black girls were showing midriff and
then they'd have
um
like a top
with some kind of [ __ ] long sleeves
that bailed out
and then they'd have a hat on top of off
afro and that was like typical high
high fashion for black girls it looked
better than the white girl version of it
it just did
there were some exceptions but it wasn't
that particular look
some white girl 70s fashion was more
like gowns
that looked good too but it looked had
nothing to do with bell bottoms
and nothing i liked the 70s gown kind of
thing but again right i kind of feel
like in the 70s
if you weren't like super scrawny a lot
of the stuff did not work on you right
except the black girl fashion was uh was
tailored towards
a full body figure more voluptuous
right whereas the white girl fashion was
more kind of like a skinny skinny yeah
real heel that was the real skinny right
man i see some movies from 70s nowadays
i'm like holy crap like that girl must
have been like not eating anything they
must have been like that weird [ __ ]
weight watcher [ __ ] you can see like
some fluffy mackerel pudding or whatever
the [ __ ] they used to put out back then
my mom was on weight watchers back in
the 70s and i'm kind of like fascinated
by because i don't know if you guys know
but
there was big thing in the 70s
weight watchers and they had all of
these [ __ ]
cards
and had a big picture
of the dish and the recipe on it and
everything was like super because weight
watchers was really restricted back then
you couldn't have any alcohol which that
would do me right away you couldn't eat
any nuts
you couldn't eat there was a [ __ ] ton of
stuff you could need
pretty much all they ate was like
lettuce cottage cheese and they would
have all these [ __ ] desserts
where
they made pretty much everything out of
like gelatin so it's like oh we're
making chocolate pie
but it's basically like gelatin with
some a little bit of cocoa in it
and like some aspartame or something and
it's like this big and it's like a
gelatin
how sad is that
how sad is that but that's what you had
to eat well and also cocaine probably
helped um to maintain
this skeletal
figure yeah that was seemingly like the
ideal in the 1970s like i said it didn't
make sense though i don't even
understand how white girls fit in those
[ __ ] pants back then it didn't matter
because they the girls were
yeah
so skinny and then like you see the
pants that they're wearing and the pants
are like tight yeah and i'm like how as
skinny as that girl is how did that
[ __ ] girl get those [ __ ] pants on
how did she get them off i don't know
it looks like they're [ __ ] painted on
i just i can't it didn't make any sense
to me
of why why you wanted to look it was a
thing it was a thing
like i said it was a cocaine it's a hell
of a drug yeah it was i guess i guess a
sign of having enough money to buy a
whole bunch to buy cocaine i guess
that's what it was you were signaling to
other people yes i can afford lots of
cocaine thank you very much
or i never eat i know my porn history
see
and a lot of the [ __ ] porn and
magazine girls that were real popular
from that era
were still the [ __ ]
that yeah
well because the mainstream beauty and
the porn beauty we're different we're
two different things not so much
nowadays now i now i kind of feel like
it's like coalesced
but back in the old days it was like two
different you know you had like what in
france it was called
back in france they called the demi bond
i guess uh you know what i mean the half
world that was like a subculture
so the porn
they liked more voluptuous women but in
the mainstream it was always kind of
like this really super super scrawny and
that kind of happened again in the 90s
too because i kind of feel like heroin
chic was kind of a thing in the 90s
where it was like super flat and like
super super thin
other than cindy crawford she was pretty
voluptuous but you know what i mean
other than that it was just kind of like
everybody looked like hi i'm on heroin
you know what i mean everybody looked
like they were just like about to
[ __ ] die
so
i don't know that it's it's a thing it
comes and goes so
uh kanavatsan says jenny are you
familiar with the sandman series netflix
is making it i don't know much about the
lore but the trailer looked good it's
graphic novel uh i have read the graphic
novels um you know if you're talking
about the neil gaiman ones uh but i
didn't know they were making a series so
i'm kind of excited about that we'll see
cheryl says i love blacula i do too i
mean blacula and scream blacula scream
are so [ __ ] good
kanavatsan also says uh also guys watch
the deep house i wrote it down i did i
wrote it down over there because i do
actually want to watch that uh caitlyn
says thank you for acknowledging laser
blast's existence
laser blast
holy [ __ ] you guys
my favorite thing about that like i said
i've never watched it on its own i've
seen it on mystery science theater many
times
the aliens look like
turtles without shells and for whatever
reason i love that whoever made the
movie decided that they were going to
give them these weird big butts
and i love that
i love that
i mean
it's a it's a hilarious movie don't like
don't watch it on its own because it's
probably lame but watch on mst it's good
victor says a lot of those states that
depend on federal government all those
poor states in the south would be third
world countries
actually that's kind of a myth
that might have might have been true
back in the 70s or part of the 80s
but uh the south now has all the space
programs all the all the manufacturing
the us used to have including tesla now
that's all in the south
um the the south
had
is in a real good position now and
another thing is is that um
if you're talking about welfare
the population that's on that here is
actually pretty small compared to say
california or new york there's not very
many people here
it's sparsely populated
and if you were to stop welfare nothing
would happen
at all
because
we didn't have that in the great
depression and we didn't have that
really to speak of when i was a little
kid living down here most people just
grew food out in the back of their homes
you could live on nothing in the south
uh
by self-generated agriculture
the south is starvation proof
um it went through
my experience but okay
now you just go back you well it depends
on how you're living in mississippi you
just go back to subsistence farming
which my grandparents generations all
did that
you don't really need a car you don't
need any television you don't even
really need electric power
to survive those are all
um
luxuries uh
you know people had no problem living
here in the 1800s
just by doing that
it's just it depends on what you're
talking about what what is modern living
that's what that's what it is luxuries
are luxuries you don't actually need
them you don't need cell phones you
don't need computers
i mean i can live that way i live that
way for years and for well you don't
make your living on a computer either i
mean i do
well the thing is if you're making a
living you're living on a computer then
you're not on welfare
you know i could use some though yeah
everybody could just the way it is
i'm not paying for this [ __ ] though i'm
like you know i just pay a little bit
for it it's just kind of like i know but
you're paying christ it's all right it's
just kind of like
i i feel like you have this thing where
i mean you grew up pretty privileged
um
yeah you did um compared to me
so i mean your parents were never on
food stamps or anything like that mine
were yeah um so i'm not [ __ ] on
anybody that needs that [ __ ] because
[ __ ] man if you're eligible for that
take it [ __ ] take it but um okay just
trying to set victor straight
oh okay
when the soviet union collapsed there
was no welfare
okay
people tried to survive however they
could
uh it got barbaric a lot of people died
but dying is a part of living
mo you know just because you're alive
i'm sure that'll make everyone feel
better tom okay
just
just because you're alive doesn't
guarantee you're just because you're
alive doesn't guarantee you anything
um we live in a savage world like
thank you thomas okay why don't you go
live in your little mad max fantasy it's
not a fantasy it's a reality
it's not that it is very much a reality
brazil was pretty much that
it's kind of the way brazil was in the
80s
most of central and south america is
like that it's just that you haven't
really seen it
you'll see
if it happens here if it happens here
you'll see and it's actually makes a lot
of sense when you see it happen it and
it's a lot
less traumatic as you actually think it
is
on says tom it's in your mind it is yeah
it's all in my mind well we were talking
about that off the screen no
he knows well he tells me dumb [ __ ] all
the time like every time like i think
something and he's like well it's in
your mind i'm like well where the [ __ ]
else would it be it's in your mind and
also
i gotta say like this is going back a
couple hours yeah when i was talking and
you interrupted me and then
i don't appreciate that you do it again
i'm gonna hit you go ahead and hit me
there don't tempt me don't attempt when
did i interrupt you
what were you talking about earlier like
a couple months a couple uh we were
talking about ice cream flavors when was
this
today yes okay i don't know like two
hours ago i'm drinking
so am i but i remember too okay
don't [ __ ] do that again i do what i
want to do no don't do that again i'm
telling you right now okay
i know where to bury i don't know what's
uh i know where to bury you no one will
find you all right okay so
don't do that [ __ ] again i'm just
telling you
here we go all right
cheryl says fight yeah
i mean
she's been drinking
it's of you yeah
but you do that well you did that [ __ ]
like uh several hours ago when you were
still ostensibly sober okay and i don't
appreciate it so just saying
um yeah kanavatsan says maybe you're
seeing the multiverse dude to be very
high that's what it's just small
diversity yeah so you know
that's why i don't listen to you
[Laughter]
picture says enter the united states
would be no bad for the economy it
probably would be honestly
well look i'm just kind of like [ __ ]
economy look
i'm just kind of deal with
as i said
i grew up
[ __ ] broke
um i'm used to being
broke i don't like it
but
whatever happens in the larger
you know economy deal with the [ __ ]
that's all it's just kind of like well i
don't like it i worry about it uh
because i don't want to starve but
you wouldn't stop um
you know but i'm just gonna like deal
with whatever happens so i don't really
like because tom really likes to get
into these whole big things oh this is
gonna happen and that's gonna happen and
this whole [ __ ] thing's gonna come
out and i'm just kind of like why like
why honestly
he gets on my case for like worrying
about [ __ ] it's like why are you
worrying about that though because
you are though because that's all you
talk about
it's like i'm not going to worry about
it because what the [ __ ] can i do about
it one night
and two it's like i'm broke anyway it's
like how the [ __ ] could it be any worse
i'll just live in my car i don't give a
[ __ ] i'll never starve i'll [ __ ]
break i'll bring angel over here and
she'd give me some rabbits and i'll just
grow some rabbits out in the back well
that's what i'm saying i'll live in my
car and i'll just like [ __ ] just
scrounge out a dumpster i don't know
well we'll see we'll see
no i'm just saying that it's like you're
going to leave what if what if you died
you just stayed up in here if you died
and then i ate you look look look and
then after i eat you what am i going to
do then oh when mad max happens and like
you know
where are you getting this because you
just said that no no no you just said it
was like mad max right now you just said
that literally like when brazil
collapsed
what ended up happening was right but
nobody had money for anything i know
you've said that happening is is that
nobody paid for anything
nobody paid for anything because there
was no way it was everybody if it
happens to you it happens to everybody
else
well that's what i'm saying and then
they had to reboot so i'm like not
worried about it yeah so i don't know
everybody's broke my ass is broke okay
but like i said literally less than 10
minutes
you said reality was like mad max and i
was just kind of like everyone know
i remember that yeah but that was a long
time ago yeah and it's different
look it's a different situation
okay
we'll see okay cool whatever it's just
kind of like don't worry about that
stupid [ __ ]
um
i'm in this [ __ ] now you do this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] worried about it because i
signed for this [ __ ] i'm here now
it's gonna take a whole army to get me
out he says he doesn't worry about it
but that's all you ever [ __ ] talk
about that's all you talk about okay and
i'm just kind of like look i don't i
can't do anything about it um i have no
money i have no power i have no nothing
since she has no money she makes money
every month this is yeah well i do but
like only enough to like pay my bills i
don't like have extra or nothing okay
all right
so it's like but okay but you know what
i mean so it's like if
you know if if some [ __ ] went bad if we
don't have the internet anymore then
obviously i'm [ __ ] so
we'd work something out
you know good works about
caitlyn says tell tom that blank is just
deployed by the government as a ready
counter argument yeah i should probably
do that
uh
john says this stream is better than any
reality tv and cheryl says jenny's
incredibly tolerant yeah tell me about
it man um
first time i've ever seen you lose your
cool oh i oh i do you guys don't know
the [ __ ] deal all the time i just try
not to do it on the live stream but you
know what i mean
he pisses me off like all the time all
the time yeah
because of that [ __ ] that you do
and that wasn't even about anything
significant that was about [ __ ] ice
cream flavors all i said was yeah
licorice ice cream that can like suck my
dick yeah whatever the [ __ ] it is you
don't know what you're talking about
licorice ice cream licorice is [ __ ]
awesome it's not
i mean i'm not saying this like i
personally she's i do not like licorice
i don't like it
other people can like it i'm not gonna
ban it or nothing you can like it but
don't do this thing where it's like oh
well that's the best thing ever and you
obviously suck because you don't like it
that [ __ ] crazy that's really lame
[ __ ] black licorice ice cream was
[ __ ] [ __ ] man well
black licorice
is
no lower your voice now she's yelling
she's yelling don't ghastly
black licorice is an acquired taste
some people like it some people do not i
do not like it but i understand that
some people do like it if you like black
licorice ice cream then by all means
have all of it i'm not having any so
it's kind of like you can have my
portion if you would like
but what are you doing to pookie look
what you're doing to pookie
look what she's sleeping what are you
talking about you're upsetting her
she's not upset she's sleeping okay
she doesn't even know what's going on
she's she's everything on
there's a distraction
it's not
but thanks for like trying to like make
me seem yeah if it's crazy i love how
you do that that's how i do that's how i
played it
hold on let me see what everybody has to
do
crazy [ __ ] look i'm on your games by now
i know i know what you're doing
i know what you [ __ ] do i know what
you [ __ ] do
[Laughter]
kanavasan says well look at the bright
side if the world collapses you don't
pay for the house yeah that's what i'm
saying exactly and people are going like
well it's easy to say that if you're
living all the [ __ ] government no
when this [ __ ] falls apart
if the [ __ ] falls apart nobody can pay
for anything
go back and read what happened during
the collapse of the soviet union and all
the eastern european societies
[ __ ] uh what happened
in brazil when i was there in the 80s
most of this [ __ ] scam if it goes bad
it's not bad just for you it's bad for
everybody and the [ __ ] system just
kind of grounds to a halt
and the meaning of money kind of
vanishes one day i woke up in brazil and
saw nothing but [ __ ]
money blowing through the streets like
it was [ __ ] leaves and everybody had
thrown their money out of the damn
window because it wasn't worth anything
and they had to [ __ ] get rid of the
cruzeiro and they came up with a thing
called a cresado that took a while and
then [ __ ] five years later they came
up with a thing called a real they kept
changing the money because the [ __ ]
zeros started to get more and more it's
like some [ __ ] out of zimbabwe or
something
but people survived it because it was
happening to everybody at once
people couldn't pay for anything but
nobody could pay for anything
so you couldn't make your way in some
ways it's kind of like i don't i don't
know if this is uh true but honestly
it's kind of like when the pandemic
happened it's just kind of like that
sucked
but
it sucked for everybody in the same way
so it wasn't as bad i know this is like
weird to say but it wasn't as bad as
like some really bad [ __ ] that just
happened to you exactly because nobody
would like understand it's like look i
had this really bad like traumatic thing
have like i lost all my money or
whatever the [ __ ] and it's so at least
you have like some people to commiserate
with at least there's like a larger
context and you have other people to
like
know what you're going through people
say there's that people think that when
a financial collapse or something like
that happens that it just happens to
them no it happens to everybody and when
that happens it's almost kind of like a
great evening
everyone's at the same level whether
you're poor which i guess is why i don't
worry about it i kind of feel like i
worry about it now but i worry about it
more
when everyone else is doing okay and
then i'm like well i'm not doing it yeah
no this is like but it actually happens
it happens to everybody and everyone is
now on the same level the rich people
and the poor people are all both broke
none of them can buy anything
that kind of happens when in europe with
the black death
a lot of people got killed off the
[ __ ] um
economy collapsed and then all of a
sudden the rich people had to pay
peasants to do work there wasn't any
more serfdom anymore yeah because and i
was nowadays because they're kind of
like oh we can't find anybody to work at
fast food restaurants i'm like gee i
wonder why because that was like a
[ __ ] shitty job and people like yeah
no [ __ ] that you know what i mean the
problem with the fast food restaurants
wasn't the pay it was the hours
they would not well it's both they
wouldn't give you the 40 hours exactly
because they don't well they don't want
to like pay for your health insurance
yeah is why
um i had that same thing happen and i
didn't work at fast food i worked in
like you know uh media or publishing
and they would always try to like cut
you down oh you're only 35 hours this
week you don't qualify for health
insurance it was like always that kind
of like the secret is to disconnect from
the system and try to make money [ __ ]
in the play i mean not everybody can do
that though but i mean
yeah that's what you try to do you want
to make money underneath the table in a
black economy
that's what you want
victor says haha back in the old days
when the show was pre-recorded tom would
always talk over jenny and now jenny's
threatening to eat him [ __ ] shut up
victor yeah
well i'm just trying to get my own back
you know
i'm a person too nobody said you weren't
a person
i guess talk
but you know like i said i i'm just
trying to like kind of get my own back
against all of the
even earlier on this show
licorice ice cream [ __ ] licorice ice
cream would you want me to leave the
show no you talked about you talked
about that and then i was talking about
i was like i don't really like licorice
ice cream and you went like this you
went
like making fun of me talking and i was
just kind of like okay okay all right
well that's nice
so
i'll leave the show if you want let's
not do that i'll leave the ship let's
not do that i'm gonna leave the show
people
i'm gonna leave the show
jenny's got it she's got it under
control well
i mean she's got out of control i'm the
one that does all the work anyways yeah
well hey
i'm gonna let you do it then cheryl says
craziest thing about the pandemic is
loss of small business
that has kind of like sucked a lot i get
it yep that was the idea though they
tried to do that the [ __ ] the people
at the very top made all the damn money
they [ __ ] doubled their money this
was all planned
no wasn't but okay
yes it was uh
i believe it was all victor says here's
some money jenny getting it to you
before tom mutes me yeah
he doesn't have one no he doesn't have
one no he's just a jerk
[Laughter]
what wig are you gonna put on now are
you gonna put on the mozart wig
put the mozart wig on
[Laughter]
caitlyn says bet probably better to raid
camp in warehouses in store especially
an employee with access to the building
yeah i mean you know
cheryl says this show needs you both it
does but i'm leaving okay oh he's being
oh he's such a snowflake he's such a
snowflake
he got mad and left
i don't know so we've been going almost
four hours and i'm kind of like hungry i
have to say so i'm gonna go get
something to eat
but
thanks for you guys like hanging around
i'm just laughing at how [ __ ]
sensitive he is uh yeah so
and pookie like shoot pookie's like
sleeping in the chair over there and she
like literally is not giving a [ __ ] but
uh yeah so
what's it okay it's friday so tomorrow
we're not gonna be on tomorrow but i
will put up a review tomorrow
and then we'll probably be back on
sunday we watched
alien versus predator
requiem
last night
and
i will say right here i thought that i
had not seen it
but when we started watching it
i did see it
i think that back in the old days when i
used to work at the newspaper in daytona
this guy i worked with named al
he used to like rent movies and then
uh you know make copies of them
illegally so he would like loan them to
me and i kind of feel like that was one
of the movies that he loaned to me
because when we were watching it i was
like wow this is like really familiar
uh we'll say
not great but honestly
maybe this is a controversial opinion
but i do kind of feel like that one was
kind of better than the first one
although it was very dark and i couldn't
tell what the [ __ ] was going on but i
couldn't tell what the [ __ ] was going on
in the fight scene than the first one
either so
i still would so i don't know but we'll
probably talk about that on sunday we'll
see
uh maybe and honestly i want to watch
the rest of the uh archive 81
series as well why is my phone ringing
okay
my phone's ringing but yeah so we might
talk about that too but tom hasn't been
watching it because he didn't really
seem interested but i think it's really
good so uh we'll see you guys again on
sunday afternoon thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats
and we oh my goodness bless you she
sneezed
um we will see you guys on sunday
afternoon tammy says thomas the jerk but
we still love
yeah it's it's kind of like it's a
conundrum isn't it but uh yeah we'll see
you guys on sunday afternoon
thank you for dropping by
bye